I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who are there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello! Hi there! Offs ladies. Hello!
我是珍妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了这部终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当时在场的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。你好！嗨！办公室辣妈。你好！
Hi there! Dun dun dun dun. It is... Roy's wedding. I mean... It's a beautiful wedding! So beautiful! Roy and Laura are getting married.
嗨！咚咚咚咚。这是……罗伊的婚礼。我是说……这是一场美丽的婚礼！太美了！罗伊和劳拉要结婚了。
In a beautiful backyard garden. I know. There's piano playing. We'll get to the stage. Champon? It is season 9 episode 2, Roy's Wedding, written by Alison Silverman and directed by Matt Sone. Here's your summary.
在一个美丽的后院花园里。我知道。有钢琴声。我们待会儿会聊到。香槟？这是第九季第二集《罗伊的婚礼》，由艾莉森·西尔弗曼编剧，马特·索恩执导。以下是本集剧情梗概。
Pam and Jim attend Roy's Wedding. Yeah. And there are so many surprises. Yeah. So many things they didn't know about Roy and his growth and it gets them to wonder. Hmm, do we know everything about one another? Or is maybe Jim keeping a giant secret from Pam?
帕姆和吉姆参加了罗伊的婚礼。没错。而且有那么多的惊喜。没错。有那么多他们不知道的关于罗伊和他的成长的事情，这让他们开始纳闷。嗯，我们对彼此真的足够了解吗？还是说吉姆有什么惊天大秘密瞒着帕姆？
Uh-oh. Meanwhile in this episode, Clark schemes to get Aaron alone in his apartment. Clark's gonna be a creeper y'all. He sure is, and Nelly is gonna use an unusual tactic to get Dwight to cooperate in her charity special project. But before we get to all of that, we have a very special treat today.
噢哟。与此同时在本集中，克拉克密谋想把亚伦单独留在他的公寓里。克拉克这回要当个偷窥狂了，各位。他绝对会的，而内莉将采取不同寻常的策略让德怀特配合她的慈善特别项目。不过在我们聊到所有这些之前，今天我们有一个非常特别的惊喜。
Yeah, Jenna is super excited because it means no fast facts. Yes, Angela, you know me very well. That's right, today it means no fast facts. Yes, Angela, you know me very well. That's right. Today, there are no fast facts. Today, our top of show is an interview with Tim Meadows. Yay! We were so excited to have Tim.
没错，珍娜超级兴奋，因为这意味着今天没有快速冷知识。是的，安吉拉，你太了解我了。没错，今天没有快速冷知识。是的，安吉拉，你太了解我了。没错。今天没有快速冷知识。今天，我们的开场访谈嘉宾是蒂姆·梅多斯。耶！我们能请到蒂姆超级兴奋。
Our regular office ladies listeners, you might remember a while back, Tim shared some tidbits with us when we broke down the episode, The Client. But we were thrilled to have him on the podcast in person. We did a Zoom. He talked about his time on the show, and we get to catch up with him. Yes.
我们《办公室》的常听众，可能还记得不久前，当我们在剖析《客户》那一集时，蒂姆跟我们分享了一些八卦。但我们非常高兴能请他本人来到播客节目中。我们通过Zoom进行了连线。他谈到了自己在剧中的时光，我们得以叙叙旧。是的。
Tim and I are also both in the new Mean Girls movie, which comes out this Friday, January 12th. We talk all about it. We talk about his time in the office and lots of other stuff. We had so much fun. We did. We got so tickled. We laughed so hard. We were all about it, we talk about his time in the office, and lots of other stuff. We had so much fun! We did! We got so tickled, we laughed so hard, we were all crying. I think there might be some pauses in this interview where you just hear three people silent laughing. Get ready for it!
我和蒂姆还一起出演了新版《贱女孩》电影，该片将于本周五1月12日上映。我们聊了很多关于这部电影的事。我们聊了他在《办公室》的时光以及其他许多事情。我们玩得太开心了。确实如此。我们笑得前俯后仰。我们太投入了，我们聊了他在《办公室》的时光以及其他许多事情。我们玩得太开心了！确实如此！我们笑得前俯后仰，眼泪都快流出来了。我想这次访谈中可能会有一些间歇，你能听到三个人在无声地大笑。准备好迎接吧！
Here it is. Oh my gosh, look who's here. It's Tim! Hi! Hello everyone! Hello. We are so excited to have you here with us. And you're going to talk a little bit about your time on the office and your new movie with Jenna. Mean girls. Let's start with the office. Tim, we always ask people how they got their job on the office. And you originally, you were offered the role and you turned it down, right? Yes, that is true.
精彩来了。哦天哪，看谁来了。是蒂姆！嗨！大家好！你好。我们很高兴你能来跟我们一起聊聊。你将会聊聊你在《办公室》的时光以及你和珍娜合作的新电影。《贱女孩》。让我们从《办公室》开始聊起。蒂姆，我们总是问大家是怎么得到《办公室》的角色。而你最初其实是收到了角色邀请，但你拒绝了，对吧？是的，没错。
I wouldn't say turned it down. I didn't turn it down to Greg and Michael Schur. I turned it down to my manager. Like he called and said, like, oh, we got this offer for this episode. And I was like, no, I don't know. I don't know if I should do it or not. Because actually, honestly, I was hoping to get paid more.
我不会说那是拒绝。我不是拒绝格雷格和迈克尔·舒尔。我是拒绝了我的经纪人。就像他打电话来说，哦，我们接到这个客串邀请了。然后我就说，不，我不知道。我不知道我该不该接。因为实际上，老实说，我希望能拿到更多片酬。
And then we had no money. It wasn't the very beginning. There was no money. It was the second season, I think. But only the second season. And NBC was not, you know, they were like not into paying me more money. And so I passed. And I just told my agent, right?
然后我们当时没钱。这不是最开始的时候。当时没钱。我想那是第二季。但只有第二季。而且NBC当时并没有，你知道的，他们不太想付给我更多钱。所以我拒绝了。我只是告诉我经纪人，对吧？
And then my manager's assistant called me back on his personal phone and said, I really think you should do this. And I don't make these kind of calls all the time. But I think that this is like one of those comedies that everybody in the industry watches. And I think you should do it. And I knew Steven, and I knew some of the other people
然后我经纪人的助理用他自己的手机给我回了电话，说我真的觉得你应该接下这个。而且我不是经常打这种电话的人。但我觉得这是业内每个人都会看的喜剧之一，我觉得你应该接。而且我认识史蒂文，我也认识剧中的其他一些人。
involved in the show too. So I was just like, okay, yeah, I'll do it. But it would have been nice if they came back and begged me, like, you know, to have a mic with Sure come back and go, hey, Tim, come on, please do this, sir. But that never happened. Okay. Well, Tim, you were our very first quote unquote stunt casting.
所以我就想，好吧，行，我接。但如果他们能回来求我，你知道的，比如让迈克·舒尔回来求我，嘿，蒂姆，拜托了，请接下这个吧，那就更好了。但这从未发生。好吧。嗯，蒂姆，你是我们的第一个所谓的特邀大牌明星。
You were our first name actor to come on the show. It was a big thing. It was a big buzz. Mm-hmm. Yes. Yeah. I do remember I was very flattered actually because I'd say almost everybody in the cast came by because we weren't on the regular office set.
你是第一个来客串的知名演员。这是一件大事。引起了很大的轰动。嗯-hmm。是的。是的。我确实记得，其实我感到非常荣幸，因为可以说剧组几乎所有人都顺道过来串门了，因为我们当时不在常规的办公室片场。
We were at the chili set. And I think I kind of remember a lot of people coming by to say hello because I was there and I was pretty impressed by that. God, I wish I had to take pictures and stuff like we do now, you know? Right, I know. I know.
我们在奇利餐厅的片场。而且我好像记得很多人都顺道过来打招呼，因为我在那儿，这让我印象相当深刻。天哪，我真希望当时能拍拍照什么的，就像我们现在这样，你知道的？对，我知道。我知道。
I didn't do any of that. There's fantastic bloopers from that day too for folks that get the DVDs. I mean, when you come in and sing, I know you're scripted to come in at the end of the line, you know, but when you start singing that, I want my baby back, baby, and then Steve comes into this. It's so great. And we had Melora on the podcast and there she is seated between the two of you. And she said it was like one of the hardest things she's ever had to do is not laugh. Yeah.
我什么都没做。对于买了DVD的观众来说，那天也有非常棒的幕后花絮。我是说，当你走进来开始唱，我知道剧本安排你是最后一句才唱，你知道的，但当你开始唱那个“I want my baby back, baby”，然后史蒂夫也接进来。这太棒了。我们之前请莫洛拉上播客时，她就坐在你们俩中间。她说那是她做过最难的事情之一，就是极力忍住不笑。是的。
In the very beginning, I remember we were trying to do it. And Steve was going like, he would start going, I want my baby back, baby back. And then I would join in with him. And then he would start singing it, but I would lose the beat. And he would go, no, no, no, do do it again, do it again. And I was like, I don't, it's a commercial. I can't, I don't know how to sing a commercial, you know. It was really fun because we started laughing at the absurdity of two grown men singing that song at the Chili's.
最开始的时候，我记得我们一直在尝试拍这一段。然后史蒂夫就开始唱，他会开始唱“I want my baby back, baby back”。然后我会跟他一起合唱。接着他会开始唱，但我却跟不上节拍了。然后他会说，不，不，不，再来一遍，再来一遍。而我就想，我不知道，这只是个广告。我不会，我不知道怎么唱广告歌，你知道的。这真的很有趣，因为我们开始为两个成年男人在奇利餐厅里唱那首歌的荒诞场景笑个不停。
Like, I was laughing at that alone, I thought it was so funny. And then these two guys were somewhat like each other. You know, like you expected Christian to be this kind of like, you know, city worker dude, but then, you know, he had all of these like private issues that came out during lunch. You know, like his mother being ill and stuff like that. Yeah, he overshared just the way Michael overshared. Yes, yes, yes, yes.
光是想到这个我就觉得好笑，我觉得这太搞笑ảnh了。然后这两个家伙有点像彼此。你知道的，就像你以为克里斯蒂安会是那种，你知道的，城市工薪族的类型，但接着，你知道的，他在午餐时吐露了所有这些隐私问题。你知道的，比如他母亲生病之类的事情。是的，他分享过头了，就像迈克尔分享过头一样。是的，是的，是的，是的。
Was it just one day of work? Did you guys get it all in one day? I think it was actually. What an epic day. Yeah, we worked our day and we ended up shooting at night thing where we were getting into cars, ain't goodbye. So we were there all day. I remember at the end,
那是只工作了一天吗？你们一天就把戏都拍完了吗？我想是的。真是史诗般的一天。是的，我们工作了一整天，最后在晚上拍了一场戏，也就是我们上车准备告别的那场。所以我们在那呆了一整天。我记得在最后，
uh, Karel improvised. I don't think they used it on the show. But he went, thanks a lot, Christian, and uh, tell your mother, good luck with her leg or something like that. Because I said, my mother like, I do her one of the improv things. I said, my mother lost her leg diabetes or something like that. But I managed to push on through. And so during one of the improvs when he was leaving, he goes, tell your mother's good love with her leg. You know what, we should remind folks that you and Steve had done seconds to be together, right? In Chicago. And so you had definitely a shorthand with one another when it came to improv, and it was so fun to watch. Yeah, he's really fun to improvise with.
呃，卡瑞尔即兴发挥了。我想剧集里没用这个片段。但他当时说，多谢了，克里斯蒂安，呃，代我祝你母亲的腿早日康复，诸如此类的话。因为我说过，我母亲像……我用了即兴发挥的梗。我说，我母亲因为糖尿病截肢了，诸如此类的话。但我还是设法坚持演了下来。所以在其中一次即兴发挥中，当他离开时，他说，代你母亲向她的腿问好。你知道吗，我们应该提醒大家，你和史蒂夫以前在第二城市剧团合作过，对吧？在芝加哥。所以当涉及即兴表演时，你们俩绝对很有默契，看你们表演太有趣了。是的，和他一起即兴表演真的很有趣。
And I had known him for a long time, but like our improv paths, we all started at the same time there, but then I sort of like jumped ahead of people a little bit, because I got hired for the main stage cast at Second City. And then he came in after I got hired. He was hired at the main stage after I went on to Saturday Night Live, but Nancy,
而且我认识他很久了，但是我们的即兴表演之路，我们都是在那个时候同时起步的，不过我稍微比其他人提前了一点进入核心，因为我被录用为第二城市剧团主舞台的演员了。然后在我被录用之后他才来。在我去《周六夜现场》之后，他被录用为主舞台演员，但南希，他的妻子也被《周六夜现场》录用了。所以那些年我们大家基本上还是保持着联系。但最有趣的是，我不知道他有没有提过这件事，但我们很久以前在华盛顿和第二城市剧团合作过一个演出，那是卡瑞尔、他的妻子南希、我自己、约翰·格雷泽、特蕾莎·罗森福尔。哦，是的。还有亚当·麦凯、大卫·科克纳。我们在芝加哥演了一场那些家伙写过的第二城市剧团的演出，但后来我们在肯尼迪中心做了一个即兴表演专场，在夏天演了大约六周。哇。
his wife also was hired at SNL. So we all still sort of kept in touch during those years. But the most fun though, I don't know if he's mentioned this, but we did this gig in DC a long time ago with Second City and it was Corral, his wife Nancy, myself, John Glazer, Teresa, Rosenfall. Oh yeah. And Adam McKay, David Keckner. We did a second city show that those guys had written in Chicago, but then we did this improv said it and it was at the Kennedy Center during the summer for like six weeks Wow
我们在每场演出结束后都有一个即兴表演环节，我告诉所有人，当他们问谁是最好的即兴表演团队时，就是你们，就是那一群人，我们是最好的即兴表演团队。我们是我合作过的最好的即兴表演团队，你知道的，就是演这种长篇即兴表演之类的。而且观众以前没看过这个。所以，他们大开眼界。他们简直不敢相信我们在说，你们是现编的吗，你们刚才真的是现编的吗？我们就说，对啊，我们已经即兴创作很久了。没错。是的，太酷了。那些家伙太棒了。真的太棒了。哦，天哪，我真希望能回到过去再看一遍。我绝对是个即兴表演迷。
We did this thing where we had an improv set after every show and I tell everybody they asked who was best improv group You it was that group of people we were the best improv group group of people. We were the best improv group that I had worked with, like, you know, doing long-form improv and stuff. And the audience, they had not seen it before. So, their minds were blown. They couldn't believe we were like, you make that up, you just made that up. We're like, yeah, we make it up for a long time. That's right. Yeah, it was cool. Those guys are great. It was really great. Oh, man, I wish I could go back and watch that. I'm such a geek for improv.
（无对话）
Yeah. This kind of leads me into my next question, which was that we were kind of part of the same NBC family at the same time, the cast of the office, the cast of SNL. We would hang out a lot together. We would have to do these NBC press events. Our lives are all completely different now. We're not on TV every week anymore. And I was just going to say, if there was a moment that you could go back and relive, what would it be? Would it be the Kennedy Center improv show?
这有点把我的话题引向了下一个问题，那就是我们当时差不多都是同一个NBC大家庭的一员，《办公室》的演员们，《周六夜现场》的演员们。我们经常聚在一起。我们必须参加这些NBC的新闻活动。我们的生活现在完全不同了。我们不再每周都上电视了。我正想说，如果有一个你可以回到过去重温的时刻，会是什么？会是肯尼迪中心的即兴表演秀吗？
Wow. Moment to go back and re- I think the moment that I love, it has a bunch. Yeah, that's a tough question, you know. Yes, tough one. But I gotta say, maybe the one would Lauren flew me out to New York. And I was just a guest and I, Tom Hanks was the host and they did the five-timers club for the first time. And I was in the office with Lauren during my meeting and then he asked me to read one of the parts in the Five Timers sketch in his office with Paul Simon, Conan O'Brien,
哇。想要回去重温的时刻——我想我喜欢的时刻有很多。是的，这是个难回答的问题，你知道的。是的，很难选。但我得说，也许是洛恩把我飞到纽约的那一次。我当时只是个嘉宾，汤姆·汉克斯是主持人，他们第一次举办了“五次俱乐部”。我在洛恩的办公室开会时，他让我和保罗·西蒙、柯南·奥布莱恩、
John Loveitz, Ralph Nader. And I was just nerd from Chicago who would, you know, I didn't, it was insane to me, you know, and as Steve Martin was there too, you know, and I was a huge, and still am, a huge Steve Martin fan. And I think in hindsight, I think Lauren was sort of testing me to see if I could handle being around famous people and stuff. But I just remember that whole week that I was there is just being like this magical thing
约翰·洛维茨、拉尔夫·纳德一起，在办公室里试读了“五次俱乐部”小品中的一个角色。而我只是个来自芝加哥的极客，你知道的，我没有……这对我来说太疯狂了，你知道的，而且史蒂夫·马丁当时也在那儿，你知道的，我是个超级，现在也是个超级史蒂夫·马丁迷。我想事后回想起来，洛恩当时可能是在测试我是不是能应付和名人在一起之类的情况。但我只记得我在那里的那一整周就像是一件神奇的事情，
where I was still in my old life, but my new life was taking me into this new place, you know? Oh, I love that. It was really great. It was that moment of just like holy cow. And I used to always think, I don't know about you guys, but like when I was on the show, there would be weeks in the first three or four weeks
我还留在我的旧生活里，但我的新生活正把我带到一个全新的地方，你知道的？哦，我太喜欢这个了。真的太棒了。那种感觉就像是我的天哪。我以前总是觉得，我不知道你们俩怎么样，但当我在那儿演出的前三四周里，
that I was there. I thought somebody from security was gonna come up during the rewrite meetings and say, that dude shouldn't be here. He was a manager of a record store about two years ago. He shouldn't be at the writing table at SNL. A rest room. Yeah, you know me and Brian and Oscar
我总是觉得在剧本重写会议期间，安保部门会有人走过来对我说，那家伙不应该呆在这里。他两年前还是个唱片店经理。他不应该坐在《SNL》的编剧桌旁。洗手间。对，你知道我和布莱恩以及奥斯卡
over there in the accounting department. We had a running joke for years where like any one of us could go at any time. Like, they don't need to be accountants. It's even a joke in the show. We could be replaced. But that is a big accounting department. I love so much just what you said about when the moment where your old life and new life are kind of intersecting, it's so true. It's kind of a surreal moment where you feel this passage of
在会计部门那边。我们多年来一直有个内部笑话，就像我们中的任何一个人随时都可能卷铺盖走人。就像，他们根本不需要真的是会计。这在剧里甚至也是个笑话。我们可以被轻易取代。但那是一个很大的会计部门。我非常喜欢你刚才说的那种新旧生活交织在一起的时刻，真的太真实了。那是一种超现实的时刻，你会感受到那种时间的流逝，
like, oh my god, but then you go back to your job. I, it's just, yeah. Yeah. What was funny, because I was like in the process of making the most money I'd ever made in my life up to that point. And I was also broke and in debt. Yeah. You know what I mean? Like, within a week, I would have cleared out my debt.
比如，哦天哪，但接着你又回去工作了。我，这真是，是的。有趣的是，因为我当时正在经历赚取我人生中最多钱的过程。但与此同时我也身无分文且负债累累。是的。你知道我的意思吗？只需一周时间，我就可以还清债务。
I would have been, you know what I mean? My first check from SNL would have made everything cool. And in the next check would have put me over, you know what I'm saying? Yeah. But yeah, it was broke and had money at the same time. Well, I would love to talk to you guys a little bit about your new movie, Mean Girls. And I got to see the long extended trailer. It looks so fun. Yeah, Tim, you are reprising your role of Principal Duval. I play Katie's mom, Ms. Heron. By the way, does Principal Duval have a first name?
我就会，你知道我的意思吗？我从《SNL》拿到的第一张支票就能把一切都搞定。而下一张支票就会让我彻底翻身，你知道我在说什么吗？是的。但没错，我当时既身无分文又身怀巨款。好吧，我很想跟你们聊聊你们的新电影《贱女孩》。我有幸看了加长版的预告片。看起来太有趣了。是的，蒂姆，你将再次出演你的角色——杜瓦尔校长。我饰演凯蒂的妈妈，赫伦女士。顺便问一下，杜瓦尔校长有名字吗？
Ooh, that's a good question. I don't think he does. I don't know. I noticed, and busy Phillips is in the movie as well, and I was talking to her about it. All of the adults are just like Ms or Mr and then a last name. They did not bother to give the adults first names. So in my dorky actor prep, I did name Ms. Heron Laura.
噢，这是个好问题。我想他没有吧。我不知道。我注意到，比茜·菲利普斯也参演了这部电影，我曾和她聊过这件事。所有的成年人都是“女士”或“先生”加上一个姓氏。他们根本懒得给成年人们起名字。所以在我的书呆子演员案头准备中，我给赫伦女士取名叫劳拉。
So it's just my own personal backstory. It doesn't. Tina Fey know that you named your, your character, Laura? Yes, I told her on set. Yes. So, uh, I didn't know if, uh, Principal DuVal had a first name, or if you, if you had considered one for him. I had not considered one, but you know what?
所以这只是我个人的角色背景故事。并没有……蒂娜·费知道你给你的角色取名叫劳拉吗？知道，我在片场告诉过她。所以，我不知道杜瓦尔校长是否有名字，或者你有没有为他考虑过一个名字？我之前没考虑过，不过你知道吗？
I, I should look at maybe the old movie or the commercial, because I know that there was like, there were diplomas on my wall behind me. Oh, yeah. So I could probably see, my guess is this is probably Anthony, because there was a play on Anthony in the first movie. Oh, yeah.
我应该去看看老电影或者那部广告，因为我知道我身后的墙上挂着毕业证书。哦，对。所以我大概能看到，我猜这大概叫安东尼，因为第一部电影里有个关于安东尼的梗。哦，对。
I hated my nephew's name. Yeah, I remember. Yeah, he hated that his name was Anthony. Oh, that's a good background catch though. We'll have to go look and see if we can zoom in on your diploma. Yeah, and I will say too, this is my maybe fourth time playing a teacher or educator with the same type of cost costume tie and sweater vest. Gold birch I did it for 10 years. Mean Girls, the first movie, the new mean girls and then school that spin off Goldbirds. I played a principal and now I'm in a new
我讨厌我侄子的名字。对，我记得。对，他讨厌自己的名字叫安东尼。哦，不过这是个很棒的背景细节。我们得去看看能不能放大看清你的毕业证。是的，而且我也要说，这大概是我第四次扮演老师或教育工作者了，穿着同款服装——领带和毛衣背心。在《戈德堡一家》里我演了10年。还有《贱女孩》第一部，新版《贱女孩》，然后是《戈德堡一家》的衍生剧。我演了一个校长，现在我参演了一部名为《梦境游乐场》的新电影，和尼古拉斯·凯奇合作，我饰演一个大学院长。你注定要从事教育事业。有创意的人只把我视为，你知道的，他们的老师之类的人物。我觉得这太疯狂了。你还记得我们在我们拍的试播集《加布里埃尔一家》里你角色的职业吗？哦！你是个老师吗？你是个了不起的老师吗？
movie called Dream Scenario with Nicholas Cage and I play a Dean of the College. You were meant to be an education. Creative people only see me as, you know, as their teachers or something. I think it's crazy. Do you remember your character's occupation on the pilot we did, the Gabriel's? Oh! Were you a teacher? You made a big teacher?
（无对话）
I think you were. As you were saying that, I was like, wait, what I think he was a teacher? I think he was a teacher. Oh my god. And I even told my agent and manager at one point, I was like, I can't do any more teacher because I kept getting other requests for roles, even just in episodic things, you know, words like, yeah, he's the principal of the, you know, it is a meeting with him in the PTA. And I'm like, I can't keep doing this
我想是的。就在你这么说的时候，我在想，等等，我觉得他是老师吗？我想他是个老师。哦天哪。而且我甚至一度告诉我的经纪人和经理，我说我不能再演老师了，因为我不断接到其他角色的邀约，哪怕只是在单元剧里，你知道的，比如，是的，他是某某的校长，你知道的，这是他和家长的开会场景。而我就想我不能再演这个了，
because people are gonna think it's kind of like connection between the things that I've, other shows that I've done, or that I'm not very versatile, you know? So either way, no more fucking principles after. Drinks and air. That ends here, this is it. It is.
因为人们会觉得这和我演过的事情、我演过的其他剧集之间有一种联系，或者觉得我戏路不够宽，你知道的？所以不管怎样，演完这个之后绝不再演他妈的校长了。梦境游乐场。到此为止，就是这个了。就是这样。
2024 is the end of the principal roles. Don't call it to meadows. You heard it here. Anymore. For teachers. I don't play tutors. I don't play teachers. I don't play instructors.
2024年是校长角色的终结。别找蒂姆·梅多斯演了。你们就在这听到了。再也不演了。演老师。我不演导师。我不演老师。我不演讲师。
Nothing where I'm giving information to people. So we should share with people that this version of Mean Girls has some musical numbers. Do you sing or dance in the movie because I don't? Ah, that was hoping you did, because I would love to see that. She would have loved to dance. She tapped dances. I can't believe you don't tap dance in this movie, Jenna. I tried. When I was on set I pulled the choreographer aside. We did you tap dancing? I thought maybe I could I don't maybe miss her in
不演任何需要向别人传授知识的角色。所以我们应该告诉大家，这个版本的《贱女孩》有一些歌舞段落。你在电影里唱歌或跳舞了吗？因为我没有。啊，我本来希望你演的，因为我很想看那个。她肯定很想跳舞。她会跳踢踏舞。真不敢相信你在这部电影里不跳踢踏舞，珍娜。我试过了。当我在片场时，我把编舞拉到一边。我们排练了你跳踢踏舞吗？我以为也许我可以，我不知道，也许赫伦女士
Has a tap number it didn't happen the sound guy hated that moment too He's like what's all that noise over there? You're like, what's all that noise over there? Jennifer Fisher, tap dancing by crap services. Again, here she goes. Actually, I do sing. You do? Oh, that's so exciting. We only had one day where we overlapped filming on this movie.
有一段踢踏舞，但没拍成。录音师也讨厌那一刻。他就像是，那边是什么噪音？而你就说，那边是什么噪音？珍妮弗·费舍尔，在餐饮服务区跳踢踏舞。瞧，她又来了。其实，我会唱歌。你会？哦，太让人兴奋了。我们在这部电影里只有一天的拍摄时间是有交集的。
Yes. I didn't see you sing that day, but I'm very excited to see this now. Yeah, I actually, they have sing that day, but oh, I'm very excited to see this now. Yeah, I actually, they had me come in and redo it recently because obviously, when I did it live, I was flat or something. I don't know what they call it, flat or sharp.
是的。我那天没看见你唱歌，但我现在非常期待看到这个。是的，其实，他们那天让我去重录了一段，因为显然，当我现场演唱时，我音准偏低或者别的什么。我不知道他们是怎么叫的，偏低或者偏高。
I was one of those things. So I came in and they were like doing that thing of like, hit it with this note here. Here in your note. I'm up here. Yes. You're down here. You're down here. Well Tim, you know, we were in walk-hard together too.
我是其中之一。所以我去了，他们就一直在做那种事，比如，用这里的这个音高。听你的音调。我在这里。是的。你在这里。你在这里。好吧，蒂姆，你知道的，我们曾一起出演过《永不止步：戴伊·科克斯的故事》。
Yes, my favorite. Let me tell you something. Yes. That is the most quoted movie to me. Really? It's a amazing movie. It is one of my, maybe my favorite movie I've ever been in. I haven't seen any girls yet.
是的，我的最爱。我跟你说件事。是的。那是人们对我引用最多的电影。真的吗？这是一部神作。它是我演过的，也许是我最喜欢的电影。我还没看过《贱女孩》呢。
Okay, so but I absolutely loved making walk-hard and I love the movie. We had so much fun. We had so much fun. What's the quote you get from that movie? For me, it's, you don't want to know part of this. Do you want to know part of this? Yeah. And then the weed, whole weed run of all the drug
好吧，但我绝对热爱制作《永不止步》的过程，我也爱这部电影。我们玩得太开心了。我们玩得太开心了。你从那部电影里听到最多的台词是什么？对我来说是，“你可沾不到这光”。你想沾这光吗？是的。然后是大麻，所有那些毒品
runs, people will say to me, you know, it's not habit forming. I think I want to try it. You don't want no part of this, do it. It takes all of your bad feelings and make them good. Well, I do really want to try. You don't want no part of this. I get that a lot. People love it. And the thing is the musicians also are big fans of that movie. I've had numerous musicians tell me that they just keep it on a loop on their tour business and they quote it. That movie I always tell people was the most fun of all the things I've done. That movie was 30 days, whatever, both just like we have fun.
的戏份，人们会跟我说，你知道的，这东西不上瘾。我想试试。你可沾不到这光，抽吧。它能带走你所有的坏情绪，把它们变成好的。好吧，我真的很想试试。你可沾不到这光。我经常听到这句话。人们太喜欢了。而且关键是音乐家们也是这部电影的超级粉丝。有很多音乐家告诉我，他们在巡演的大巴上一直单曲循环这部电影并背台词。我总是告诉别人，那部电影是我做过所有事情里最开心的。那部电影拍了30天，不管是怎样，我们就是玩得很开心。
Laugh so hard. Chris Parnell and Matt Besson. Oh my gosh. Chris Parnell. With those guys too. And I had no Matt Besson forever and had never really hung out with him that much. And then we became really good friends. Even now we're like way closer than we've ever been.
笑得前俯后仰。克里斯·帕内尔和马特·贝瑟。哦天哪。克里斯·帕内尔。也和那些家伙在一起。我认识马特·贝瑟很久了，但从来没有真正跟他一起玩过那么多。然后我们成了非常要好的朋友。甚至现在我们比以往任何时候都要亲密。
And Chris Parnell, we're less friends. We're less friends. Screech at Chris. Chris reached out to town. I don't know. Our birthdays on the same day. So every year, we text each other. We call each other Mr. Like Mr. Parnell. Busy Phillips and I have the same birthday. We do similar thing. We always text each other on our birthdays. Brian, Franston and I have the same birthday.
至于克里斯·帕内尔，我们是普通朋友。我们是普通朋友。向克里斯大喊。克里斯联系了蒂姆。我不知道。我们的生日在同一天。所以每年，我们都会发短信给对方。我们称呼对方为先生，比如帕内尔先生。我和比茜·菲利普斯同一天生日。我们也会做类似的事情。我们总是在生日那天给对方发短信。我和布赖恩·科兰斯顿同一天生日。
Do you text each other? No, we don't. No. Come on, Brian, step up. Brian, this is the year. No more educational roles for Tim, and this year, you're texting Brian. OK.
你们会发短信吗？不，我们不。不。拜托，布赖恩，支棱起来。布赖恩，今年就是时候了。蒂姆不再出演教育类角色了，而今年，你要给布赖恩发短信。好的。
That sounds good. Yeah. Well, you know, Tim, on walk-hard, they had me take singing lessons, and they had me record my voice. And then the director, Jake Kaz, came up to me a few weeks later and he was like, you know what, Jenna, you're a fantastic actress. Uh-oh. And you're so funny in the film.
听起来不错。是的。好吧，你知道，蒂姆，在《永不止步》剧组，他们让我去上声乐课，还让我录制了自己的声音。然后导演杰克·卡斯几周后找到我，他对我说，你知道吗，珍娜，你是个出色的演员。噢哟。而且你在电影里太搞笑了。
But we're going to go ahead and just replace your voice with the woman who did the practice track. Um, but great, great effort. We're still going to use your face. Yeah. Don't get me wrong now. Your lip syncing is really strong. But so maybe the mean girls people heard and maybe the word without saying I don't know it was the most awkward conversation oh that's so funny Jake was sleeping in his bed one day it was like
但我们决定直接用录了小样那个女人的声音来替换你的声音。不过，干得漂亮，干得漂亮。我们还是会用你的脸。对。别误会我的意思。你的对口型假唱真的很强。所以也许《贱女孩》剧组听到了，也许没说出口，我不知道，那真是一次尴尬的对话。哦，太搞笑了。杰克有一天在床上睡觉，电话响了
ring hello hi to mean girls people why did you tell us she's terrible I am in a couple of musical numbers and mean girls, which was I- In the real one. Yeah, I'm very excited about it because you know they're all dancing or singing around me. So I got to observe it. They're like stay out of this. They're like just standing there. Please just stand on your mark, please. Will you please stand there and watch us be talented?
铃声响起，喂，你好，是《贱女孩》剧组吗，你为什么告诉我们她演得很烂？我在《贱女孩》里有好几段歌舞，我是说——在真正的电影里。是的，我对它非常兴奋，因为你知道他们都在我周围载歌载舞。所以我得以在一旁观摩。他们就像是，离远点。他们就像是，就站在你的标记上。求你了，就站在你的标记上好吗？求你了，能站在那儿看我们展现才华吗？
Yes. I mean, amazing. Here's my moment. I had to sing Little Drummer Boy in front of the whole bullpen of the office. I remember that. And Harold Rames was directing. And I kept losing the tune. He came up and he was like,
是的。我是说，太惊艳了。轮到我了。我不得不在《办公室》整个办公区前演唱《小鼓手男孩》。我还记得那件事。哈罗德·雷米斯在执导。但我一直在走音。他走过来对我说，
it's little drummer boy. You know what I mean? Like, he didn't say it, he was so kind, but he implied like, how can you lose the beat on little drummer boy? The rap of Bob Bob. What else you look at? That's it.
这是《小鼓手男孩》。你知道我的意思吗？就像是，他没有明说，他太好了，但他暗示的是，你怎么能在《小鼓手男孩》上走音呢？哒哒哒。你还看什么？就是这样。
But I told him I was like, you're old, I can't do this, I can't sing. And he's like, but you will. The single patient is in the lyrics, okay? You understand? The single patient is in the lyrics. No, I was like so embarrassing. You guys should the three of us do a musical.
但我告诉他，我说，我都这把年纪了，我做不到，我不会唱歌。而他说，但你会的。音准就在歌词里，好吗？明白了吗？音准就在歌词里。不，我当时觉得太尴尬了。你们俩——我们三个人应该去演个音乐剧。
A musical. The three of us. Like Tim, you will shine. You will shine. In our three person musical, you will be... I would stand out. You will. I would stand out.
一部音乐剧。我们三个人。就像蒂姆，你会大放异彩的。你会大放异彩的。在我们三人的音乐剧中，你将会……我会脱颖而出的。你会的。我会脱颖而出的。
Finally. It will be s***. Unfortunately though, I started kind of pitching on it and you will need to play a teacher. A teacher? It's an eight grade teacher. If I can sing and play a teacher, forget it. I'm in. Okay. If we mention there's not a lot of money, but it doesn't matter. Doesn't matter for the art. It was so fun. Thank you so You guys for coming on office ladies. Yeah. Oh, it's my pleasure.
终于。这会很糟糕。不过遗憾的是，当我开始提出构思时，你需要扮演一个老师。一个老师？是个八年级老师。如果我能唱歌还能演老师，那算了吧。我加入。好吧。如果我们提到片酬不高，但没关系。为了艺术，无所谓。太有趣了。非常感谢你们二位能来参加《办公室-辣妈》播客。是的。哦，我的荣幸。
Well, you know, I listened to the show obviously, but when you were on the set, you told me to listen because I was Steven, it's just something nice about me. And it was very nice. And I played it for my kids. It's just a really. Yeah, he said I was a great improviser. kids just did really yeah he said I was a great improviser and it was like one of the things I'm very proud of being you know good at so it was nice. Oh I love that. All that makes us so happy. I would also say about him that he is also quite average at improv. Quite average.
好吧，你知道的，我当然听这个节目，但当你在片场时，你让我去听，因为我是史蒂芬，这对我来说是件美好的事。这真的很棒。我放给我的孩子们听了。这真的很……是的，他说我是个很棒的即兴演员。孩子们真的听了，是的，他说我是个很棒的即兴演员，这是我非常引以为傲的一项擅长技能，所以这感觉很好。哦，我太喜欢这个了。所有这些都让我们感到非常开心。我也想顺便说说他，他在即兴表演方面其实也相当平庸。相当平庸。
Can he play that for his kids? Yeah. Can he Can he play that for his kids? Yeah. Can he play the play that for his kids? Steve Tim was on office ladies and we have a clip you might want for your kids. He says you're a... You're quite average. Quite average. Keep at it buddy.
他可以把这个放给他的孩子们听吗？可以。他可以……他可以把这个放给他的孩子们听吗？可以。他可以把这个放给他的孩子们听吗？史蒂夫，蒂姆上过《办公室-辣妈》播客，我们有一段你可能会想放给孩子们听的音频。他说你是……你相当平庸。相当平庸。继续加油，老兄。
He's great. He's great. Tim before we let you go, what are you up to now? Well, actually, I am about to head out to London in Barcelona to do some long-form improv with some friends of mine. Matt Walsh from Bright Citizens Brigade. Love Matt.
他太棒了。他太棒了。蒂姆，在我们让你离开之前，你最近在忙什么？好吧，其实，我正准备前往伦敦和巴塞罗那，和我的几个朋友一起做长篇即兴表演。来自 upright citizens brigade 的马特·沃尔什。我爱马特。
Yeah. K&I and Joe Canali and Brad Morris, two friends of ours from Chicago. We got invited to come to London. We got a couple of more European invitations, so we're gonna do this other trip again, but yeah, January we're gonna be out there. It's gonna be great.
是的。K&I 以及乔·卡纳利和布拉德·莫里斯，我们在芝加哥的两个老朋友。我们受邀去伦敦。我们还收到了其他几个欧洲国家的邀请，所以我们要再次开启这段欧洲之旅，是的，一月份我们要去那边。这将会很棒。
Okay, this great. This great, all the details we'll put it in our office ladies pod stories, so folks can come find y'all. Okay, I will. Well, everybody, please go watch our movie Mean Girls. It comes out this Friday, January 12th. It's your last chance to see Tim Meadows
好的，太棒了。太棒了，所有详情我们都会放在我们的《办公室-辣妈》播客故事里，这样大家就能找到你们了。好的，我会的。好了，各位，请去看我们的电影《贱女孩》。本周五1月12日上映。这是你看到蒂姆·梅多斯的最后机会了
in an educator role, so take advantage of that. And it's a chance to see me standing my other, singing dance around me. Cee-jana, stand in one spot. Oh, I can't wait. I can't wait. You got me crying. I'm crying over here. Oh.
扮演教育工作者角色，所以好好把握机会吧。这也是看我站在另一个地方、看大家在我周围载歌载舞的机会。瞧珍娜，就站在一个地方。哦，我等不及了。我等不及了。你把我弄哭了。我都快哭了。哦。
Thank you for having me. Yes, absolutely. We are back. My heart is full. Tim is so wonderful. I love him. What a treat! Alright, before we get into this episode, I feel like we need a little call sheet tidbit. Already? Already from Steve Burgess, I got all the call sheets. And I have to share this just right away. Y'all, it was the week of August 6th when we shot this episode. Monday, the first day of filming was the coolest day of the week. It was 98 degrees.
谢谢你们邀请我。好的，绝对的。我们回来了。我的内心充满感动。蒂姆太棒了。我太爱他了。真是个惊喜！好吧，在我们进入这一集之前，我觉得我们需要一点通告单的小八卦。已经有了？已经从史蒂夫·伯格斯那里拿到了，我拿到了所有的通告单。我必须马上分享这个。各位，我们拍这一集的时候正是8月6日那一周。周一，拍摄的第一天是一周中最凉爽的一天。气温是98华式度。
Wow. We're getting a triple digits real fast. Yeah, this was a hot week, and this is gonna come up later when I discuss some location challenges based on this heat Well, let's get into this cold open. It's a personal favorite of mine. It's the chore wheel. Jenna, have you made a chore wheel in your real life?
哇。气温飙升到三位数的速度真快啊。是的，这一周非常热，稍后当我讨论基于这种高温的一些外景拍摄挑战时，还会提到这一点。好吧，让我们进入这个冷开场吧。这是我的个人最爱。那是值日轮盘。珍娜，你在现实生活中做过值日轮盘吗？
No, you would think I had. Chore chart. Chore anything. Chore lists. I bet there's chore lists. Yeah, we have a whiteboard. Okay, right that counts. That's a chor- board? Chor- board. Okay. I really regret not keeping the chor- wheel. Oh, the chor- wheels. I wanted the mini- wheel, I wanted the bigger wheels. I begged Phil Shea for them.
没有，你可能会以为我有。值日表。任何值日。值日清单。我敢打赌肯定有值日清单。对，我们有一块白板。好吧，那算数。那是值日板？值日板。好吧。我真的很后悔没有留着那个值日轮盘。哦，值日轮盘。我想要迷你轮盘，我想要大一点的轮盘。我求了菲尔·谢伊好久。
But there were not multiples of these chor- wheels. There was one of each, and he had to put them in storage in case we ever used them again on the show. You know, there's a possibility that choreweel could come back. It could have been a thing. Yeah, so I couldn't take it. And I just wish I would have remembered when the show was over.
但这些值日轮盘没有多余的备份。每种只有一个，他必须把它们收进仓库里，以防我们在剧里再次使用。你知道的，那个值日轮盘有可能还会回归。它本可以成为一个标志的。对，所以我拿不到。我只是希望在剧集结束时我能想起来把它拿走。
That's what I'm kicking myself about. Yeah, the mini choreweel, like sitting on a bookshelf, would be amazing. Right. I did see online this young Gallant College made herself a mini chore wheel, like Pam's for her dorm room. People are so crafty. Well, I guess we should describe what happened. Yes.
这就是我現在肠子都悔青的地方。对，那个迷你值日轮盘，放在书架上一定太棒了。没错。我确实在网上看到有个叫加兰特的大学女生为她的宿舍自己做一个迷你版的值日轮盘，就像帕姆的那样心灵手巧的人真多。好吧，我想我们应该描述一下发生了什么。是的。
Pam gets to work and there's like trash everywhere. Oh, it's disgusting. I guess the janitor of the building is on vacation, and Dwight isn't gonna hire a temporary replacement, so everybody has to do their own cleaning up. And no one is doing it. So Pam makes her chore wheel? Yes!
帕姆去上班，发现到处都是垃圾。哦，太恶心了。我猜大楼的管理员去度假了，而德怀特又不打算请临时工来代替，所以每个人都得自己打扫卫生。而且根本没人去打扫。所以帕姆就做了她的值日轮盘？是的！
But nobody likes it because it doesn't spin. I would like to point out that Pam has fancy nail polish again. Yes, this time it's a burgundy color. Mm-hmm. Also at 16 seconds, I really enjoyed the detail fancy nail polish again. Yes. This time it's a burgundy color. Also at 16 seconds, I really enjoyed the detail that Dwight is sitting at his desk and not participating in the conference for a day.
但没人喜欢它，因为它转不起来。我想指出的是帕姆又做了一次精致的美甲。是的，这次是勃艮第酒红色。嗯-hmm。同样在16秒处，我非常喜欢一个细节：又做了一次精致的美甲。是的。这次是勃艮第酒红色。同样在16秒处，我非常喜欢一个细节，德怀特坐在他的办公桌前，一整天都没有参与这个会议。
Yes. He's watching from afar. Would you like a breakdown of Pam's original choreo wheel? Sure. Here are the chores. Clean restrooms, water plants, replace lights, wash windows, mug duty, vacuum, clean kitchenette, sweep entrance, empty trash, dust off machines, and clean break room. The second chore
是的。他在远处观望。你想听听帕姆最初的值日轮盘都有哪些项目吗？当然。以下是各项值日。清洁洗手间、浇花、更换灯泡、擦窗户、洗马克杯、吸尘、清洁小厨房、清扫入口、倒垃圾、擦拭机器灰尘以及清洁休息室。第二个值日
wheel has the exact same categories, but it just spins. Yes, no one was impressed. And the final chore wheel spins and has all new categories, which are bankrupt. Go home now, exclamation point. Manager for an hour, candy bar, punch in the gut, ten bucks, creed's choice, warehouse vacation, no internet, tiny wheel, Stanley gets your lunch, and spin again.
轮盘有完全相同的分类，但它只是会转动。是的，没有人被打动。而最后的那个值日轮盘会转动，并且有了全新分类，分别是：破产、现在回家，感叹号。当一小时经理、糖果棒、肚子挨一拳、十美元、克里德的选择、仓库假期、没有互联网、微型轮盘、斯坦利帮你买午餐，以及再转一次。
Well, that is certainly a much more fun wheel. Yeah, it is. There's ups and downs on that one. 10 bucks. I wanna get that one. But the original one is all chores. And when Kevin spins, it gets mug duty. Everyone's like, this thing sucks.
好吧，那绝对是一个好玩得多的轮盘。是的，确实如此。那个上面有起有落。10美元。我很想转到那个。但原本那个全都是杂务。当凯文转到时，抽中了洗马克杯。每个人都觉得，这东西太烂了。
Yeah. We got a fan question from Maddie R. and Dallas, Texas, who said, in the cold open when Kevin's spin lands on mug duty, Pam explains that this means he has to clean all the mugs in the sink. I have never worked in an office, so maybe I'm wrong, but isn't it weird that people don't clean their own mugs? Is this something that the custodial staff would do? Why can't everyone just wash their own mug for the time being? Well, lady, this took me down a rabbit hole.
是的。我们收到了来自德克萨斯州达拉斯市的Maddie R.的粉丝提问，她说，在冷开场中，当凯文转到的格子是洗马克杯时，帕姆解释说这意味着他必须洗水槽里所有的马克杯。我从来没在办公室工作过，所以也许我弄错了，但是大家不洗自己的马克杯不是很奇怪吗？这是保洁人员会做的事吗？为什么大家不能顺手把自己用的马克杯洗了呢？好吧，各位，这个问题把我带进了一个知识盲区。
I Googled mug cleaning culture in offices. You did, kids. I did. I Googled, what are the top 10 chores people hate doing the most? In offices or in life. In life. Why don't we start with your mug cleaning? And then I'll tell you the top 10 most hated chores according to the internet. Great.
我在谷歌上搜索了办公室里的马克杯清洗文化。你搜了，孩子们。我搜了。我搜索了：人们最讨厌做的前10大家务是什么？在办公室里还是在生活中。在生活中。我们为什么不从你的马克杯清洗开始聊起呢？然后我再告诉你根据互联网统计的最讨厌的10大家务。太棒了。
All right, well, I thought about this because when we worked at the Ear Wolf offices, I would always have the instinct to clean my own mug, but I noticed that it was the culture of the office to just leave your mugs and glasses in the sink and it was part of the front desk. The person who worked the front desk would always clean all the mugs. We just had community mugs and glasses in the sink and it was part of the front desk. The person who worked the front desk would always clean all the mugs. We just had community mugs.
好吧，我之所以想到这个，是因为当我们在Ear Wolf办公室工作时，我总是本能地想洗自己的马克杯，但我注意到办公室的文化就是把你的马克杯和玻璃杯直接留在水槽里，那是前台的工作一部分。在前台工作的人总是会清洗所有的马克杯。我们只有公用的马克杯和玻璃杯留在水槽里，那是前台工作的一部分。在前台工作的人总是会清洗所有的马克杯。我们只有公用的马克杯。
I don't know if people brought their own in, but I just always use the community mug, which never really bothered me until I was digging deeper into this basic office coffee mug etiquette. And I found out of really disturbing fact that I can't unthink now. About coffee mugs? Uh-huh. At work? Uh-huh. I found a study that was done by total jobs that found that one in five communal office mugs contain fecal matter. What? Because 25% of people don't wash their hands after they go to the bathroom. Ah! Yeah. Oh my God, we have to bring our own mugs everywhere.
我不知道人们是不是从家里带了自己的杯子来，但我总是用公用马克杯，这从来没有真正困扰过我，直到我更深入地了解了这种基本的办公室咖啡杯礼仪。我发现了一个非常不安的事实，现在我想忘都忘不掉了。关于咖啡杯的？嗯-hmm。在工作场所？嗯-hmm。我发现了一项由Totaljobs进行的研究，该研究发现，每五个办公室公用马克杯中就有一个含有粪便物质。什么？因为25%的人上完厕所后不洗手。啊！是的。哦天哪，我们得到处随身带自己的杯子了。
That's what it said. It said you really need to bring your own mug and wash your own mug. And then take it home. Or bring it back. Or like, hide it in your desk. Put it in your drawer. Yeah. I feel like-
研究就是这么说的。它说你真的需要带自己的杯子，并且自己洗杯子。然后把它带回家。或者带回来。或者像，把它藏在你的办公桌里。放进抽屉里。对。我觉得——
Just disgusting. I know. And this feels like a time when I have to remind everybody that I always wash my hands after number two And I always wash my hands. Oh because of the one time space I just sometimes don't wash my hands every time I tinkle in my own house. Okay, that's all But I'm not putting any fecal matter on any mugs I just want to get that out there and clear that up for anybody who's got to come for me in the comments
简直太恶心了。我知道。我觉得这个时候我必须提醒大家，我在大号之后总是会洗手。而且我总是洗手。哦，因为有一次……我只是有时在我自己的家里尿尿时不是每次都洗手。好吧，仅此而已。但我绝对没有在任何马克杯上留下任何粪便物质，我只是想把这一点说清楚，为任何准备在评论区攻击我的人澄清一下。
I just want to get that out there and clear that up for anybody who's got to come for me in the comments. This study also found that the average office desk has 400 times more bacteria than a toilet seat. So if you're going to eat lunch at work, you're going to want to wipe that space down before you eat. And you should also wash your reusable water bottle every single day. So like, don't leave it on your desk overnight and then come into work and just start drinking out of it again because it's not sanitary and the water will breed bacteria and you could get sick. Oh, I do that all the time. I know. I just leave a water bottle on my desk and I just pick right back up with it. I know. You're drinking some bacteria. Okay. But you're not drinking people. I am not. You are not drinking fecal batter. I am not you are not
我只想把话说清楚，好让那些打算在评论区攻击我的人无话可说。这项研究还发现，普通办公桌上的细菌是马桶座圈的400倍。所以如果你要在公司吃午饭，吃之前最好把桌子擦干净。而且你每天都应该清洗你的重复使用水瓶。所以，比如，别把它留在桌上过夜，然后第二天上班直接拿起来喝，因为这很不卫生，水会滋生细菌，你可能会生病。哦，我经常这么干。我知道。我就是把水瓶留在桌上，然后拿起来接着喝。我知道。你这是在喝细菌。好吧。但你喝的不是人。我没有。你喝的不是粪便。我没有，你没有
Wow, okay, I'm gonna look at the communal coffee mugs differently anywhere I go now Yep, I'm using one right now Well before we get to my top 10 chores people hate I want to share Pam's talking head and the chore that Meredith gets Hmm, Pam says she's been through several stages of development of the chore wheel with her team. Who's her team? There's no team.
哇，好吧，我以后去任何地方看待公共咖啡杯的眼光都要变了。没错，我现在就正用着一个呢。好吧，在我们聊大家最讨厌的10大家务之前，我想分享一下潘的访谈，以及梅代丽斯抽到的家务。嗯，潘说她和她的团队一起经历了好几个阶段的家务轮值表开发。谁是她的团队？根本没有团队。
I think that's herself. I'm like, Pam, there's no team. You're trying to sound fancy. And she's added incentives. We've talked about it. $10 candy bar. And then Meredith gets tiny wheel. And everyone starts cheering.
我觉得那是她自己。我就想，潘，根本没有团队。你这是想装高雅。而且她还加了奖励。我们之前聊过。10美元的巧克力棒。然后梅代丽斯抽到了小小轮盘。接着大家都欢呼起来。
Pam spends it and it lands on toilets. And they're like, woohoo! And Meredith was like, yay, toilets! She seems so happy to clean toilets, but let me tell you, according to the internet, cleaning the bathroom slash toilets is number one on the chores people hate. It's one of my favorite chores.
潘转动轮盘，指针停在了厕所上。大家就喊：呜呼！梅代丽斯则说：耶，厕所！她看起来打扫厕所都这么高兴，但老实说，根据网上的数据，打扫浴室加厕所是人们最讨厌的家务第一名。这可是我最喜欢的家务之一。
Really? I love all water-based cleaning. Bathrooms, kitchen, sink, dishes. I like that you've given it a category. Yeah. Water-based cleaning. If I'm using like water, you like it. I like it.
真的吗？我喜欢所有跟水有关的清洁。浴室、厨房、水槽、洗碗。我挺喜欢你还给它归了个类。对啊。水基清洁。只要是用水的，你就喜欢。我喜欢。
Number two is washing the dishes. You probably like it. It's water-based. I don't mind it. Number three, cleaning the stove top and oven. Okay, I don't care for that. Yeah. It's very greasy business.
第二名是洗碗。你可能挺喜欢。因为要用水。我不介意。第三名是清理炉灶和烤箱。好吧，我可不喜欢那个。对啊。那可是油污重灾区。
And also it's like a lot of little corner. Oh, nooks. Number four, doing laundry and ironing. Oh, that's a big sigh. You don't like doing laundry. It depends on the day. Okay. Dusting.
而且还有好多死角。哦，缝隙。第四名是洗衣服和熨衣服。哦，这叹气叹得真大声。你不喜欢洗衣服。这得看那天的心情。好吧。掸灰尘。
Hate. Hate dusting. Move it up to number one. For me. Number six, sweeping and vacuuming. Number two. I don't mind it at all. I love to vacuum.
讨厌。讨厌掸灰尘。把它提到第一名。对我来说。第六名是扫地和吸尘。第二名。我一点也不介意。我超喜欢吸尘。
It's great. Like, yeah, I like to see the grooves in the carpet. I don't know, it's so fun. I hate dry cleaning, dusting vacuuming. Don't care for it. Okay, this is your category, water-based or dry cleaning. Next up is mopping. It's the one wet activity I don't like.
太棒了。就像，对啊，我喜欢看地毯上的纹路。不知道为什么，太好玩了。我讨厌干洗、掸灰尘和吸尘。完全不感兴趣。好吧，这就是你的分类，水基清洁或干洗。接下来是拖地。这是唯一一项我讨厌的湿式清洁活动。
Okay, you've got one. Oh, next one. Grocery shopping and cooking. Yeah, these are things people don't like doing, guys. Number nine, cleaning the windows. I love cleaning windows. I don't mind it. You know why? It's like an immediate result.
好吧，你中了一个。哦，下一个。买杂货和做饭。对啊，这些都是大家不喜欢做的事，伙计们。第九名是擦窗户。我超喜欢擦窗户。我不介意。你知道为什么吗？因为能看到立竿见影的效果。
I think that's what I like. And lastly, cleaning the gutters. I don't want to clean the gutters. Josh cleans the gutters. I don't want to clean the gutters. I also can't reach even on our tallest ladder. Sure. It's so interesting that that one was included. You know what? They didn't include on that list. Maybe this just falls under laundry, but this would be real high on my list of things I hate doing. Sheets. Yeah.
我想这就是我喜欢的原因。最后是清理屋檐排水槽。我才不想清理排水槽。乔斯去清理排水槽。我才不想清理排水槽。而且就算踩着我们最高的那把梯子我也够不着。确实。真有意思，这个居然也上了榜。你知道吗？他们没把这个列入榜单。也许这只是归在洗衣服里面，但这绝对会在我讨厌做的事的清单上名列前茅。床单。对啊。
Putting sheets on a bed, making a bed from scratch. I don't mind making a bed that already has covers on it. Yeah. I don't mind that. I don't mind. Like the fitted sheet doesn't bother me. I'm very lucky because I feel like Lee and I we balance each other. Like the things I hate, he doesn't mind. Yeah. If we're going to clean up the house, he does all the vacuuming. He just like gets on it. And I'm happy to do the bathrooms. It's interesting. We never talked about it. It just sort of happened.
铺床单，从头开始铺床。我不介意铺一张已经有床罩的床。对啊。我不介意这个。我不介意。比如装床笠不烦人。我很幸运，因为我觉得我和李互补得很好。比如我讨厌的事，他都不介意。对啊。如果要打扫房子，他会包揽所有的吸尘工作。他就是很积极。而我很乐意打扫浴室。挺有意思的。我们从没商量过。就自然而然成这样了。
Same with Josh and I. We just sort of found our strengths or something. Yeah. Just leaned into them. Exactly. Well, this cold open is going to end with Meredith trotting away, very excited to clean some toilets. Then we're going to zoom in on a little rat.
我和乔斯也一样。我们就是自然而然找到了各自擅长的领域之类的。对啊。顺其自然。没错。好吧，这个冷开场将以梅代丽斯小跑着离开、兴高采烈地去打扫厕所而告终。然后镜头会拉近拍一只小老鼠。
That's walking around Dwight and Jim's desks. This rat was of course from Bob Dunns. Where do they keep all these animals? They have dogs, cats, porcupines, rats, squirrels, where are they? I'd like to see them. Do they live together? Bob Dunn has a farm.
它在德怀特和吉姆的桌子周围走来走去。这只老鼠当然是来自鲍勃·邓恩。他们把所有这些动物都养在哪里？他们有狗、猫、豪猪、老鼠、松鼠，它们都在哪儿？我想见见它们。它们住在一起吗？鲍勃·邓恩有个农场。
That's what I like to think. I don't know, it's so interesting to me. Anyway, Steve Burgess said he thinks that the rat cost about $200 a day. We had to hire it for two days. It needed its training day and a shooting day. And we also had to pay for the trainer plus transportation. So in the end, it was about $1,500 to get that shot of the rat.
我倒挺愿意这么想的。不知道，这对我来说太有意思了。总之，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说他觉得那只老鼠一天的费用大约是200美元。我们不得不租用它两天。它需要一天训练时间和一天拍摄时间。而且我们还得付驯兽师的费用加上交通费。所以最后，为了拍到那个老鼠的镜头，大约花了1500美元。
That rat shot. In the trash. Well, you know, there was part of me when we saw that little rat that really wanted Aaron or Darryl to have a name for it, because we know they've been feeding mice for years. Maybe they know this, dude. Yes, maybe Darryl has a little top hat for it. Yeah. Oh, that would have been cute.
那个老鼠镜头。在垃圾桶里。好吧，你知道的，当我们看到那只小老鼠时，我内心深处真的很希望埃伦或达里尔给它起个名字，因为我们知道他们喂老鼠好多年了。也许他们认识这家伙。是的，也许达里尔给它准备了一顶小礼帽。对啊。哦，那太可爱了。
Well, the show is going to open. We're at Jim and Pam's house. They're loading up the car, Cece's playing in the front yard. Looks like she has her little snuggle blanket on her head. She has the same little lovey that my kids used. Oh yeah! So cute! Well, per the call sheet this day, the high was 101 degrees.
好吧，剧集要开始了。我们在吉姆和潘的家里。他们正在装行李，西西在前院玩耍。看起来她头上顶着她的小安抚毯。她用的小毛毯跟我孩子用的一模一样。哦，对呀！太可爱了！好吧，根据这天的通告单，最高气温是101华氏度。
It was Tuesday. We also had a table read this day for Andy's ancestry. And I thought you might like to have a little get to know your cast and crew moment. Oh! Alright, sounds good. I have two for this episode. First one up was Edward Nielsen III from our camera and electrical department. Here are things you didn't know about Ed Nielsen.
那天是星期二。我们这天还进行了一次剧本围读，读的是《安迪的祖先》。我想你可能会喜欢一个“了解你的演员和剧组”的小环节。哦！好吧，听起来不错。我这集准备了两个。首先登场的是来自我们摄影和灯光部门的第三代爱德华·尼尔森。以下是关于埃德·尼尔森你不知道的事。
It says, oh, where to begin, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, four dots. Ed speaks orcish. Mrs. having no responsibility in his childhood and looks forward to doing nothing on the weekends. When asked about time travel, he said it is BS and for Trekkies. And of course, my folks that love Lord of the Rings, you know orkish is the primary language of the orks. Oh, I didn't know that. It is the main language of the horde. So it's made up. It's made up language. Oh, I didn't know it. When you said it. Okay, you had a blank look on your face. I was like, oh, I this must be some sort of Nordic language. I didn't know what it was. I was like,
上面写着，哦，从何说起呢，点，点，点，点，四个点。埃德会说半兽人语。童年没有任何责任，并期待在周末什么都不做。当被问及时间旅行时，他说那是胡扯，是给星际迷航迷准备的。当然了，我那些喜欢《指环王》的朋友们，你们知道半兽人语是半兽人的主要语言。哦，我不知道。它是兽人部落的主要语言。所以它是编造的。这是编造的语言。哦，我不知道。当你这么说的时候。好吧，你当时一脸茫然。我心想，哦，这肯定是什么北欧语言。我不知道那是什么。我当时想，
so impressive. I didn't know he spoke that. I would have read that and then gone up to him and be like, oh my God, you speak this, where is it from? What is Orkish? Yes. I'll have you know, Angela, we shot this scene first up in the day. It was very, very early to avoid the heat. We're going to see Jim in a talking head.
太厉害了。我不知道他会说那个。我要是读到这个，然后就会走过去对他说，天哪，你会说这个，这是从哪来的？什么事半兽人语？是的。我得告诉你，安吉拉，我们那天一大早首先拍摄的就是这场戏。为了避开高温，拍得非常非常早。我们会看到吉姆的单人访谈。
He's all dressed up. So is Pam. He explains they are going to Roy's wedding at 8 a.m. Yeah. We got a fan mail flurry about this, Ange. Oh, yeah. People want to know why would Pam and Jim go to Roy's wedding? Why would they even be invited? Okay, well, there was a deleted storyline
他盛装打扮。潘也是。他解释说他们要去参加罗伊上午8点的婚礼。对啊。安吉，我们收到了雪片般飞来的粉丝邮件。哦，是吗？大家想知道，为什么潘和吉姆要参加罗伊的婚礼？为什么他们甚至会被邀请？好吧，其实有一个被删掉的故事情节
in last week's episode, New Guys, right? Right. And it sets up this Roy's wedding storyline. I really debated about sharing it last week, but then I thought, I don't want to give away any spoilers. So I'm going to share it this week. Okay. Jim and Pam have a scene where they discuss what they're buying Roy for his upcoming wedding. Oh, yeah. And they're at their desk. They're looking at the wedding registry website. And then there was a Pam talking head about it. Let's hear it. Roy Anderson, my former
在上一集的《新人》里，对吧？没错。它为这个罗伊婚礼的剧情做好了铺垫。我本来很纠结要不要在上周分享它，但后来我想，我不想剧透。所以我打算这周分享。好吧。吉姆和潘有一场戏，他们讨论要给即将结婚的罗伊买什么礼物。哦，对啊。他们坐在办公桌前。他们在看婚礼注册网站。然后有一个关于这个的潘的单人访谈。我们来听听。罗伊·安德森，我的前
fiance, is getting married unless his bride pulls what I'm sure they call a Pam or that bitch Pam. And wait, there was a candy bag alt that was a must shoot. So you did say this to the camera. Here was an alt talking head. Pam would have said, Roy Anderson, my former fiance is getting married. What do you get for a man whose butt you've seen thousands of times? Okay.
未婚夫，要结婚了，除非他的新娘也干出他们肯定会叫作“潘”或者“那个碧池潘”的事。等等，还有一个糖果袋的备用镜头，那是必须拍的。所以你确实对镜头说了这个。这是一个备用的单人访谈。潘原本会说，罗伊·安德森，我的前未婚夫要结婚了。你该送什么给一个你屁股看过几千次的人呢？好吧。
And I zoomed in on the wedding registry website. Uh huh. They decide to get Roy a ladle, right? Like a fancy ladle. Okay. And Pam's like, that doesn't seem like a lot. Jim's like, I don't know, get him the spoon too. I looked, the ladle cost $174.
然后镜头拉近了婚礼注册网站。嗯哼。他们决定送罗伊一个汤勺，对吧？就像一个精致的汤勺。好吧。然后潘觉得，这好像不太够。吉姆就说，我不知道，把大勺也送给他吧。我查了一下，那个汤勺价值174美元。
Whoa. Yeah. Well, my question is, how big is this ladle? Because that gift that they're carrying out of Jim and Pam's house, that box is very long. I know, I thought that too. I'm like, what is that the ladle, the spoon, clearly they went another way? Well, we got another fan question
哇。好吧，我的问题是，这个汤勺到底有多大？因为他们从吉姆和潘家里搬出来的那个礼物，那个盒子很长。我知道，我也这么想。我在想，那是汤勺、大勺吗？显然他们选了别的东西？好吧，我们还有一个粉丝提问
from Kyle C. and Stockton, California, who said, a wedding on a morning of a work day at 8 a.m. Huh. Huh. Well, Kyle, I want you to know that Jenna and I have a mutual friend who got married very early on a Saturday morning and did a breakfast reception. And I went up to our friend at the reception and I was like, this is so pretty. I've never been to a wedding this early.
来自加利福尼亚州斯托克顿的凯尔·C，他说，婚礼定在工作日的早晨八点？哈。哈。好吧，凯尔，我想让你知道，我和珍娜有个共同的朋友，他周六一大早结婚，办了一个早餐招待会。我在招待会上走到我们朋友面前说，这太美了。我从来没参加过这么早的婚礼。
And our friend leaned into me and said, eggs are cheap. Well, give any names, but you know what, it can be a very cost effective wedding, which we're going to find out soon that Roy didn't need a cost effective wedding. So it does beg the question, why is Roy's wedding at 8 AM on a week day? Yeah, we never get an answer. But on her way to the car, Pam has grabbed a banana because she's pretty sure that Roy is not going to have great food.
然后我们的朋友靠在我耳边说，鸡蛋很便宜。好吧，就不说名字了，但你知道吗，这可以是一场非常划算的婚礼，我们很快就会发现罗伊其实并不需要一场划算的婚礼。这就让人不禁要问，为什么罗伊的婚礼要在工作日的早上8点举行？对啊，我们一直没有得到答案。但在去车上的路上，潘拿了一根香蕉，因为她确信罗伊不会提供什么好吃的。
He's probably going to serve hot dogs. They're being like snarky about the wedding. Like what is this thing going to be? It's Roy. I know, but Pam's like, I planned a wedding with Roy. He wanted hot dogs. Jim's looked at cameras like, again, how weird is this? So I'm going to my wife's ex-fiancé's wedding.
他可能会端出热狗。他们对这场婚礼冷嘲热讽的。就说什么样的人才会办这种婚礼？这可是罗伊。我知道，但潘就觉得，我以前跟罗伊一起筹划过婚礼。他当时就想要热狗。吉姆看着镜头，仿佛在说：再次感叹，这有多诡异？我居然要去参加我老婆的前未婚夫的婚礼。
Yeah, Pam planned a whole wedding with this person. Now we're gonna head over to Dunder Mifflin and Pete and Clark have arrived to the office. They tend to do things in Unison all the time. Have you noticed? They arrive at exactly the same time. They take a break at the same time. Yeah.
对啊，潘曾经跟这个人筹划过整个婚礼。现在我们要去邓德米夫林了，皮特和克拉克已经到了办公室。他们俩总是步调一致地做事情。你们注意到了吗？他们刚好同时到达。他们同时休息。对啊。
These guys are joined at the hip. It's interesting. But it doesn't seem like by choice. Like it doesn't seem like Pete wants to be joined with who are. With who are? No. Aaron has one piece of mail for the customer service department and she's going to give it to Pete this time.
这两个家伙形影不离。挺有意思的。但看起来好像不是自愿的。因为看起来皮特并不想和“谁”形影不离。和“谁”？没有。埃伦有一封信是给客户服务部门的，她这次要把它交给皮特。
She's dividing it up. Yeah. There's a little banter between Pete and Aaron and gosh, the way he looks at her, he's so charmed by the fact that sometimes she writes nice letters to customer service departments. He's like, that's the sweetest thing. I know. It's cute. I like cute. It's a little bit of a meat cute. It's a little bit of a meat cute and I'm just gonna say right now, I like how Pete looks at her. Yeah, I do. Yeah.
她在分发信件。对啊。皮特和埃伦之间有一些打趣，天哪，他看她的眼神，他被她有时会给客服部门写暖心信件这件事迷住了。他觉得，这太贴心了。我知道。很可爱。我喜欢可爱。这有点像浪漫邂逅。这有点像浪漫邂逅，我只想说，我喜欢皮特看她的眼神。对啊，我也喜欢。对啊。
I think they want me to root for this romance and I already am. I'm already on board. We just don't want Erin and Andy to end up together. I think we're gonna bring anyone in. We're like, okay. Well, you guys will remember that Nelly says, her real specialty is special projects.
我觉得他们是想让我支持这段浪漫关系，而我已经开始支持了。我已经入坑了。我们就是不想让埃伦和安迪在一起。我觉得无论谁来插一脚都行。我们就会觉得，好吧。好吧，大家会记得内莉说过，她真正的专长是特别项目。
And she's got a new special project. Her new special project is the launch of Operation Gift Back. She's passing out flyers to everyone. It's her new charity initiative. Andy has rejected all of her special project proposals, but this one is for charity. So she'd like to see him piss on this one. She's going to address the bullpen and say there's $4,000
她有一个新的特别项目。她的新特别项目是发起“回馈行动”。她正在向所有人分发传单。这是她的新慈善倡议。安迪拒绝了她所有的特别项目提案，但这个是做慈善的。所以她想看他在这件事上也吃瘪。她要对大办公室的人宣布说有4000美元
to give to charity, and they get to pick the charities. So she wants everyone to sort of make suggestions. Yeah. Stanley is going to suggest the American Diabetes Foundation. Angela finds this to be a selfish choice. Yes. He has diabetes.
捐给慈善机构，由他们来挑选慈善机构。所以她想让大家提提建议。对啊。斯坦利建议美国糖尿病基金会。安吉拉觉得这是一个自私的选择。是的。他有糖尿病。
Creed wants to help Jimmy Carter build gnomes. Does that just get tossed out there and no one reacts to it? No one reacted. Toby has an idea, but he gets interrupted. And finally, Dwight announces he's not gonna participate due to the lack of evidence that charity works. Nelly tells Dwight the participation is mandatory.
克里德想帮吉米·卡特建造地精。这话就这么随口一说，没人反应吗？没人反应。托比有个想法，但他被打断了。最后，德怀特宣布由于缺乏证据证明慈善事业有用，他将不参加。内莉告诉德怀特，必须参加。
So he says, fine, I pick the global relief foundation. By the way, it was recently discovered to be a front for the Taliban. And everyone's like, oh, Dwight. I know. I'd like to point out that Nelly has a beautiful bouquet of roses on her desk. Oh, I don't know why.
于是他说，好吧，我选全球救援基金会。顺便说一句，这个基金会最近被发现是塔利班的幌子。然后大家都说：哦，德怀特。我知道。我想指出的是，内莉的桌上有一束美丽的玫瑰花。哦，我不知道为什么。
Do they compliment her fancy chair? She doesn't have her fancy chair anymore. Oh, no. I guess she had to take fancy chair? She doesn't have her fancy chair anymore. Oh, no. I guess she had to take it home because Andy doesn't have it either. Mm-hmm. I know. Well, now we are gonna go to Roy's wedding.
难道是在称赞她那张漂亮的椅子吗？她没有那张漂亮的椅子了。哦，不。我想她不得不把它拿回家，因为安迪也没有那张椅子。嗯哼。我知道。好吧，现在我们要去参加罗伊的婚礼了。
It looks lovely. It's like a garden wedding outside. Yes, I guess it's in his backyard. Bob Vance and Phyllis are there. Darryl and Val are there. Yeah. Roy's gonna greet Darryl. He's happy.
看起来真不错。就像是一场户外的花园婚礼。是的，我猜是在他的后院。鲍勃·万斯和菲利斯也在那儿。达里尔和瓦尔也在。对啊。罗伊去迎接达里尔。他很高兴。
He looks great. Yeah. Super handsome David are there. Yeah. Roy's gonna greet Darryl. He's happy. He looks great. Yeah. Super handsome David Denman. Yeah. There's a tray of mimosas going by. And Jim and Pam are gonna arrive. Pam's still eating her banana.
他看起来状态很好。对啊。超级大帅哥大卫·德曼也在那儿。对啊。罗伊去迎接达里尔。他很高兴。他看起来状态很好。对啊。超级帅的大卫·德曼也在那儿。托盘上装着含羞草鸡尾酒。吉姆和潘到了。潘还在吃她的香蕉。
They're walking up the driveway and they're greeted. By a waiter, he's got mimosas on a silver tray. This waiter has maybe my favorite line of the entire episode. It's some real good like side eye snark. Mm, he says, would you like me to take your peel? Mm, I just want to know. But it was really funny. We got a lot of mail about this opening scene.
他们沿着车道走过来，受到了迎接。一个侍者拿着一个银托盘，上面放着含羞草鸡尾酒。这位侍者说的台词可能是整集中我最喜欢的。那是一种非常棒的斜眼冷嘲热讽。嗯，他说，需要我帮您拿一下皮吗？嗯，我只想知道。但这真的太搞笑了。我们收到了很多关于这个开场镜头的邮件。
Fan question from Alice in W and Winnipeg, who said, do Jim and Pam live really close to Roy? Why was Pam still eating her banana when they arrived to his house? Or maybe Pam just savors eating a banana? Oh, this is like some deep, deep leaning into banana time. Like what is your banana clock? Well, Alice, and I'll tell you, in real life,
温尼伯的爱丽丝·W的粉丝提问，她说，吉姆和潘是住在离罗伊很近的地方吗？为什么当他们到达他家时，潘还在吃她的香蕉？或者说潘只是很享受吃香蕉的过程？哦，这简直是对“香蕉时间”的深度沉迷。你的香蕉时钟是怎么走的？好吧，爱丽丝，我来告诉你，在现实生活中，
Pam and Jim's house is an entire day away from Roy's house because we shot these on different days. I'll tell you, in real life, Pam and Jim's house is an entire day away from Roy's house. Oh. We shot these on different days. And also, when Pam is leaving her house, she hasn't started eating her banana yet. That was a choice I made because I knew I was gonna have to still be eating it when I arrived. So I think we were thinking that she just waited
潘和吉姆的家距离罗伊的家足足有一天的路程，因为我们是分不同天拍的。我来告诉你，在现实生活中，潘和吉姆的家距离罗伊的家足足有一天的路程。哦。我们是分不同天拍的。而且，当潘离开家的时候，她其实还没开始吃香蕉呢。那是我做出的选择，因为我知道等我到达目的地时我还得继续吃着它。所以我想我们当时的设定是她只是在车里
to eat it in the car. By the way, that's also why I gave myself the business of fudzing with my earring as I walked out of a house. I wanted you to believe like maybe I got my car and still fudzing with myself. I believed it. You sold it. Thank you. Thank you.
等着吃它。顺便说一句，这也是为什么我走出家门时给自己加了弄弄耳环的戏份。我想让你相信，也许我上了车还在摆弄自己。我信了。你演得真好。谢谢。谢谢。
I ate a banana on my drive in this morning. Yeah. I have about a half hour drive and I only ate half my banana. But you always only eat half your food. That's true. Yeah, you fill up fast. I can't, you've a tiny stomach.
我今天早上开车来的路上吃了一根香蕉。对啊。我大概有半小时的车程，我只吃了一半香蕉。但你总是只吃一半食物。这倒也是。对啊，你饱得很快。我不行，你的胃太小了。
I can't really be part of this banana time conversation. Well, speaking of locations, Roy's house was filmed at a house on Ventura Canyon in Sherman Oaks, and Steve Burgess reminded me that we ran into a number of logistical problems at this location, many based on the extreme heat. Angela, do you have a temperature for me? I do per the call sheet. The day you filmed these scenes was Thursday, August 9th, and the
我实在没法参与这个“香蕉时间”的话题。好吧，说到拍摄地点，罗伊的家是在谢尔曼奥克斯文图拉峡谷的一处房子里拍摄的，史蒂夫·伯吉斯提醒我，我们在那个拍摄地点遇到了很多后勤问题，其中很多都是因为极端高温造成的。安吉拉，你有当天的气温记录吗？根据通告单，我有。你们拍摄这些场景那天是8月9日星期四，
high was 103 degrees. Yeah. It was hot and it was sunny. So we had to bring in a condor. Not the bird. Oh, the crane. Mm-hmm. To try to shade it. So we had to bring in a condor, not the bird. Oh, the crane. To try to shade it. Yeah. We had to put up this huge, it's called a fly swatter in the biz, little biz lingo for you.
最高气温是103华氏度。对啊。又热又晴。所以我们不得不叫来一架神鹰直升机。不是那只鸟。哦，是起重机。嗯哼。用来遮阳。所以我们不得不叫来一架神鹰，不是那只鸟。哦，起重机。用来遮阳。对啊。我们不得不支起这个巨大的东西，在行话里叫苍蝇拍，这是给你们科普的小行话。
And it's just like a huge piece of sherry silk material. They hang it really high over the location so that it lets in light and it's not like too low on us, I guess, but every time the sun would move, we would have to move the fly swatter. So it would have to be like, oh my gosh, it's like a big thing to move, it's an enormous crane. Yeah. We also had to move it from the front of the house to the back of the house, and it was really time-consuming, and Steve Burgess sent me pictures of it. So you can put them in our Instagram stories. Oh, I will.
它就像是一大块雪纺绸材料。他们把它挂在拍摄地点的上方很高处，这样既能透光，又不会离我们太近，我想是这样的，但每当太阳移动，我们就得移动那个“苍蝇拍”。所以就得，哦天哪，移动它可是一件大事，那是个巨大的起重机。对啊。我们还得把它从房子前面移到房子后面，真的很耗时间，史蒂夫·伯吉斯还发给我照片了。所以你们可以把它发到我们的Instagram故事里。哦，我会的。
We also got a fan question from Marissa D and San Jose, California, who said, Jenna, how many times did you have to eat that banana? I hope only once. Marissa, it wasn't only once. How many times? It was a lot of times. That's all I remember. When I watched the scene, I was like, I ate so much banana, but I was really committed to it. But I also had a spit bucket. So any banana that was
我们还收到了加利福尼亚州圣何塞的梅丽莎·D的粉丝提问，她说，珍娜，你到底吃了多少根香蕉？希望只有一次。梅丽莎，可不止一次。多少次？有很多次。我只记得这个。当我看到这个场景时，我就想，我吃了好多香蕉，但我真的是全身心投入。不过我还有一个吐口水的小桶。所以场景结束时剩下的任何香蕉，
left when the scene was over, I got to spit it out, you know. Yeah. So I probably ate half as much bananas. It seems like I ate. You're always thankful for a spit bucket when you're doing scenes like this. I mean, remember how sick Reign got when he had to eat all the bananas? Because he didn't spit them out. I know. You know, bananas are a binding food. They will mess you up if you go too hard. Yeah. You shouldn't eat that much banana, you know,
我都可以吐出来，你知道的。对啊。所以我大概只吃了看起来一半数量的香蕉。拍这种戏的时候，你总是会很庆幸有个吐口水桶。我是说，还记得雷恩拍完那些不得不吃所有香蕉的戏时病得有多惨吗？因为他没有吐出来。我知道。你知道的，香蕉是一种会让人便秘的食物。如果你吃得太猛，身体会吃不消的。对啊。你可不能一次性吃那么多香蕉，你知道的。
in one sitting. All right, next up, van question from Kaden M in Warrenville, Illinois. Jenna, was it scripted that you put the other half of the banana on the plate or was that an ad lib? It's one of the funniest moments in the whole show. I agree.
好吧，接下来，来自伊利诺伊州沃伦维尔的卡登·M的粉丝提问。珍娜，你把另一半香蕉随手扔在盘子里的动作是剧本里写好的，还是即兴发挥的？这是整部剧中最搞笑的时刻之一。我同意。
I agree. When the waiter says, can I take your peel and she flops it on the tray and grabbed a mimosa. I was like, oh, I like this Pam. This Pam is ready to take on this wedding. Well, this was a scripted moment and here's what it said. It was scripted that Pam quote,
我同意。当服务员说“需要我帮您拿一下皮吗”，她随手把香蕉皮啪嗒一下扔在托盘上，然后抓起了一杯含羞草鸡尾酒。当时我就想，哦，我喜欢这个潘。这个潘已经准备好迎接这场婚礼了。好吧，这是一个剧本里写好的时刻，剧本上是这么写的。剧本写道，潘“
awkwardly stuffs the rest of the banana in her mouth and gives the peel to the caterer. The caterer, by the way, it was played by David Britz and we had a good time. He was great. Well, during this banana business, Jim is gonna get a phone call. He's been getting lots of phone calls.
笨拙地把剩下的香蕉塞进嘴里，然后把香蕉皮递给餐饮服务人员。”顺便说一句，这个餐饮服务人员由大卫·布里茨饰演，我们合作得很愉快。他演得真好。好吧，在这个香蕉小插曲期间，吉姆接到了一个电话。他最近接了很多电话。
He's been shady about him too. He jokes to Pam that it's his ex-fiancé, and then he has a talking head, where he shares that he has started a new business with his college friend and Pam doesn't know. Well, actually, he told Pam, but then they decided no, but then he decided yes anyway. So he thinks there's going to be another conversation coming.
他对这些电话也遮遮掩掩的。他开玩笑对潘说是他的前未婚妻，然后他有一个单人访谈，在访谈中他透露自己和大学朋友合伙做了一笔新生意，而潘还不知道。好吧，其实，他之前告诉过潘，但后来他们决定不干了，不过后来他又决定不管怎样还是要干。所以他觉得接下来还会有一次谈话。
Oh, big sigh. Yeah. So he's now just shared with the camera crew of this documentary. Pam's going to have to watch this someday that he has gone behind her back and is keeping the secret. And now a lot of people know but Pam. Yeah. Well now we're going to see a scene where Jim approaches Roy. Yeah. I'm calling this scene snark alert.
哦，长叹一声。对啊。所以他现在只是向这部纪录片的摄制组透露了这件事。潘总有一天会看到这个，知道他背着她隐瞒了这个秘密。现在很多人都知道了，唯独潘不知道。对啊。好吧，现在我们要看一场吉姆走近罗伊的戏。对啊。我把这场戏叫作“讽刺警报”。
Well it's good that you did, Lady, because I thought there was some snark and I went to the shooting draft and it says as Jim approaches in parentheses, a little snarky. Oh! Uh-huh! Look! Snarky! In the shooting draft, when Jim says, is it almost time to cut the pancake or what?
好吧，你这么叫很好，Lady，因为我觉得里面确实带着讽刺，我去查了拍摄初稿，上面写着吉姆走近时，括号里写着，带点讽刺。哦！嗯哼！看！讽刺！在拍摄初稿里，当吉姆说，“是快到切煎饼的时候了还是怎么着？”
What a dick. What a snarky thing to say. Who is Jim season 9? Who is this guy? Ah! Roy couldn't be lovelier. He's so gracious. He said, you know what?
真是个混蛋。说的话真够讽刺的。第九季的吉姆是谁？这家伙是谁？啊！罗伊态度好极了。他太亲切了。他说，你知道吗？
We appreciate everyone coming out so early. It's just been so nice. And also, listen, he wouldn't have met Lara if it hadn't been for Jim, right? Yeah. And then Roy does get a dig in. He says, really dodged a bullet on that one, am I right? Haha. Yeah.
感谢大家这么早就赶来。真是太美好了。而且，听着，要不是因为吉姆，他也不会遇到劳拉，对吧？对啊。然后罗伊确实讽刺了回去。他说，“那一枪躲得真妙，我没说错吧？哈哈。”对啊。
But then, all of a sudden, we're going to find out that Roy has a $50,000 car. Well, wait. He started a gravel company and it just took off. And then Roy's brother Kenny walks up and says to Roy, hey, bro, stop wasting time with this haircut and points to Jim. And that's when he shares that he has a $50,000 sports car. I know. Once you know Kenny's scripted line was, stop wasting time with this limp dick.
但紧接着，突然之间，我们发现罗伊居然开着一辆价值5万美元的豪车。等等。他开了一家碎石公司，生意一下子就火了。然后罗伊的弟弟肯尼走过来对罗伊说：“嘿，老哥，别跟这个发型奇特的人浪费时间了”，并指了指吉姆。就在那时，他透露自己有一辆价值5万美元的跑车。我知道。其实肯尼原本的剧本台词是：“别跟这个软蛋浪费时间了。”
Hi, that's making me love. That's really funny. We had a fan question to Angela from Shelby A and Huntsville, Alabama, who said, we see Roy and Jim interact at Roy's wedding. Was there anything scripted between Pam and Roy? I'm so curious what they would have said to each other after all those years. Well Shelby, I was really curious about this too.
哈哈，这让我觉得很好笑。我们收到了来自阿拉巴马州亨茨维尔的谢尔比·A发给安吉拉的粉丝提问，她说，我们看到罗伊和吉姆在罗伊的婚礼上互动。潘和罗伊之间有什么剧本安排吗？我很好奇他们历经多年后会对彼此说些什么。好吧，谢尔比，我也对此非常好奇。
I went to the shooting draft. There are no scenes with Roy and Pam, but there might be a reason why she never makes it to Roy because she gets some serious shade from his parents. So in the shooting draft it said, Pam stands awkwardly with two drinks. She is clearly heading back to Jim when Roy's parents stop her. And I think you got to hear it. It's in deleted scenes. She gets some serious shade. We just love Laura. I couldn't imagine a better daughter-in-law. It's great to see Roy so happy.
我查看了拍摄初稿。里面没有罗伊和潘的对手戏，但也许有原因解释为什么她从未走到罗伊身边，因为她受到了他父母的一番冷嘲热讽。所以在拍摄初稿里写着：潘手里拿着两杯饮料，尴尬地站着。她明显正准备走回吉姆身边，这时罗伊的父母拦住了她。我想你们应该听听看。这在删减片段里。她受到了狠狠的冷嘲热讽。我们太喜欢劳拉了。我想象不出比这更好的儿媳妇了。很高兴看到罗伊这么幸福。
Oh, he's the happiest he's ever been. How wonderful. Laura is really easy to get along with. And she's loyal. Which is what I think Roy needs. Nice to see you again, Pam. Thank you. Be well.
哦，他是他有生以来最快乐的时候。太棒了。劳拉真的很好相处。而且她很忠诚。我想这正是罗伊所需要的。很高兴再次见到你，潘。谢谢。保重。
And so, Pam is just left there standing awkwardly with two drinks. And she never makes it over to Jim and Roy. So maybe that's why there's no scene between Pam and Roy. Oh, I remember shooting that scene. That was so fun. I love the dad as he walks away. He just goes, be well.
于是，潘就那么尴尬地手里拿着两杯饮料站在那里。她始终没能走到吉姆和罗伊身边。所以也许这就是为什么潘和罗伊之间没有对手戏吧。哦，我记得拍那场戏的时候。太好玩了。我喜欢他爸爸走开时的样子。他只说了一句，“保重。”
Yeah. So now you thought the biggest creeper Dunder Mifflin had left. Yeah, well we said goodbye to Robert California. We thought all of the perversion left with him, but we were wrong and oh were we wrong. Clark is just as bad as Robert California. Yeah, I mean, dare I say he's worse.
对啊。所以现在你以为邓德米夫林最大的变态已经离开了。对啊，我们跟罗伯特·加利福尼亚道别了。我们以为所有的变态都跟他一起走了，但我们错了，天哪，我们错得离谱。克拉克和罗伯特·加利福尼亚一样糟糕。对啊，我是说，我敢说他更糟糕。
Yeah, he's in the break room. He and Pete are side by side per usual, and they're having a snack. Aaron is seated at a different table. Clark is gonna take a phone call. Clearly the person on the other line is asking if he knows anyone who could be a newscaster. Because you know, that's how you become a newscaster,
对啊，他在休息室里。他和皮特像往常一样并排坐着，在吃零食。埃伦坐在另一张桌子旁。克拉克要接个电话。很显然，电话那头的人在问他认不认识什么可以当新闻主播的人。因为你知道的，当新闻主播就是这样的，
everybody. Yeah, that's how it happens in the break room at the paper company. It doesn't require a journalism degree. No, Yeah, that's how it happens in the break room at the paper company. It doesn't require a journalism degree. No, no, no. It just requires a creep making a fake e-phone call to try to get a girl back to his house. What a creep. Yeah.
各位。对啊，造纸公司的休息室里就是这么回事。这根本不需要新闻学位。不，对啊，造纸公司的休息室里就是这么回事。这根本不需要新闻学位。不，不，不。这只需要一个变态打个假电话，想把一个女孩骗回他家。真是个变态。对啊。
Pete doesn't like this. No. He has a frown. He's also drinking out of a hers potato chip mug. Oh. Little shout out to hers. Yeah. Yeah, Clark convinces Aaron to make this audition tape, right?
皮特不喜欢这样。不。他皱起了眉头。他手里还拿着一个赫尔斯薯片杯在喝东西。哦。顺便给赫尔斯打个小广告。对啊。对啊，克拉克说服埃伦去试镜录像，对吧？
Yeah, come to his house. Yeah, maybe you have a few different wardrobe looks, some lipstick, some wine to loosen up. Yeah. Pete has a talking head where he says, you know what, I'm not friends with Clark, he's just the douche sitting next to me at the office. Yeah, Aaron says she never thought about being more than a receptionist. That's
只是她应聘的广告而已。如果她应聘的是首席执行官或脑外科医生之类的工作呢？对啊。她本来可以胜任这两者中的任何一个。对啊。好吧，听着，这可能是一个好机会，告诉任何有志成为演员或出镜名人的朋友，你绝对不能去别人家里试镜。事情根本不是那样的。而且你知道吗？这似乎显而易见，但其实我刚到洛杉矶时，《洛杉矶周报》上有很多看起来挺正规的试镜，结果却发生在别人的
just the ad that she answered. What if she had answered an ad for another job like CEO or a brain surgeon? Yeah. She could have been either of those. Yeah. Well, listen, this might be a good place to tell anybody who is an aspiring actor or on air personality that you should never go to an audition in someone's home. It doesn't happen that way. And you know what? It seems obvious, but actually when I first came to LA, there were a lot of what looked like legitimate auditions in like the LA weekly that happened to take place at people's
家里。当时得有人提醒我千万别去。对啊。哦，当然。我记得当时有张传单，说什么我在拍独立电影，举行试镜，但地点竟然是在他家的车库里。你知道的，然后你会想，哦，好吧，这是独立电影嘛。也许他们预算有限。对啊。也许他们是为了这个项目而在家办公。不，别去。我是说，别去任何人家里。听着，我们之前已经讲过我当年去盖斯特公寓面试国际辣妹组合广告时发生了什么了。
houses. And I had to have someone tell me not to do that. Yeah. Oh, for sure. I remember there was like a flyer like I'm making an independent movie, holding auditions, but they were like at his garage at his house. You know, and you're like, oh, well it's independent. Maybe they're on a budget. Right. Maybe they're working out of their home for this project. No, don't go. I mean, don't go to anyone's house. Listen, we already told the story of what happened when I showed up for the international Spice Girls commercial in the Geist condo
没错，珍娜。好吧，所以遗憾的是，没有人提醒埃伦。好吧，我们会讲到的。皮特会尝试——我手里有删减片段的内容，但我等会儿事情发生时再分享。我们为什么不休息一下，我挺期待听那个的。好的。我们回来了，罗伊要向他的新娘祝酒。他们太幸福了。是的，他的妻子劳拉由萨拉·蔡斯饰演。你猜怎么着？他为她准备了一个惊喜。他确实准备了，你知道吗？劳拉以为他在上拳击课，但你猜他其实一直在干什么？
Right. Yes, Jenna. Okay, so Unfortunately Aaron doesn't have anyone cluing her in. Well, we'll get to it. Pete's gonna try I have something from deleted scenes, but I'm gonna share it later when it happens Why don't we take a break and I'll look forward to hearing that. Okay. We are back and Roy is going to toast his bride. They're so happy. Yes, his wife, Laura, was played by Sarah Chase. And guess what? He has a surprise for her. He does, you know? Laura thought he was taking boxing lessons, but guess what he was doing the whole time?
在上钢琴课，这样他就能在婚礼当天为她弹奏小夜曲。是的，他开始唱比利·乔尔的《她逃走了》。潘和吉姆不知该作何反应。菲利斯和鲍勃在热吻。他们吻得难舍难分。拍摄初稿里确实写着达里尔擦掉了眼角的一滴泪。噢。
Taking piano lessons, so he could serenade her on their wedding day. Yes, he starts to sing, She's Got Away by Billy Joel. Pam and Jim do not know what to make of this. Phyllis and Bob make out. They make out hardcore. It did say in the shooting draft that Darryl wipes a tear from his eye. Aww.
他为他的死党感到高兴。根据通告单，弹钢琴的场景拍摄于8月10日星期星期五，当天的最高气温也是103度。好吧，我们收到了伊利诺伊州维罗妮卡·L的粉丝提问，她说，大卫·德曼真的在婚礼招待会的场景里弹钢琴了吗？
He's so happy for his buddy. Per the call sheets, the piano scene was filmed on Friday, August 10th, and the high this day was also 103. Well, we got a fan question from Veronica L. in Illinois who said, did David Deadman play the piano in the wedding reception scene?
不，维罗妮卡，他是装的。嗯哼。当镜头特写他的手时，他弹了前几个音符，然后我们把镜头拉远，但你会发现镜头再也没有特写过他的手。他是在假装，实际上有一个名叫马修·恩克斯特的钢琴师在摄像机拍不到的地方弹着另一架
No, Veronica, he's faking. Mm-hmm. He played the first couple of notes when we're close up on his hands and we pull back, but then you'll notice the camera never shows his hands again. He was pretending and an actual piano player by the name of Matthew Enkst was playing another
钢琴，好让大卫跟着唱。他们那天早上7点钟开了一个小型钢琴排练，正是在那个时候他们教大卫怎么弹奏那几个开场音符。我当时就在现场，非常非常迷人。你知道的，能把大卫请回来我真的超级兴奋。他是早期拍摄时我最好的朋友之一，后来我们不经常见面，就有点失去联系了。讽刺的是，这场婚礼的大部分时间我都是和罗伊在一起。
piano off camera so that David could sing along. And they met for a little piano rehearsal that morning at 7 in the morning and that's when they taught David how to play those opening notes. And I was there for that and it was very, very charming. You know, I was just so excited to have David back. He was one of my best friends from the early days of shooting, and we'd lost touch a little bit after we weren't seeing each other all the time. I spent most of this wedding, ironically, with Roy.
和罗伊在一起，作为潘。叙旧叙的是你的朋友大卫。完全是这样。我们还收到了来自澳大利亚悉尼尼基塔·C的一个非常有趣的粉丝理论，她说，是达里尔教罗伊弹钢琴的吗？因为当罗伊坐下来弹奏时，是达里尔在大喊并鼓励他。女士们怎么看？
With Roy as am. Catching up with your friend, David. Completely. We also had a really fun fan theory from Nikita C in Sydney, Australia, who said, did Daryl teach Roy the piano? Because as Roy sits down to play, Darrell is the one to call out and encourage him. What do you ladies think?
嗯，我很喜欢这个主意。我也是。我挺喜欢的。而且，在拍摄初稿里，写到了达里尔有多骄傲，他都感动得流泪了。对啊，我愿意相信他是偷偷溜去向达里尔学钢琴的。好吧，我愿意相信他是偷偷溜去向达里尔学钢琴的。好吧，我想是时候看看通告单上的另一个
Well, I love that idea. Me too. I do. And also, in the shooting draft, it had how proud Darrell was and he's tearing up. Yeah, I like to believe that he was sneaking off to learn piano from Darrell. Well, I like to believe that he was speaking off to learn piano from Darryl. Well, I think it's time for another
“了解我们的演员和剧组”环节了。这是关于我们的部门主管化妆师勒韦恩·卡库西·米拉佐的，关于勒韦恩你不知道的事。勒韦恩会说意大利语。她去过的最美的地方是马尔代夫。她上学时想成为一名考古学家，她初次接触电影和电视世界是在一个非工会的王子音乐录影带上。
get to know our cast and crew moment from the call sheet. This is about our department head makeup artist, LeVern, Carcousey Milazo, things you didn't know about LeVern. LeVern speaks Italian. The prettiest place she has ever been is the Maldeves. When she was in school, she wanted to be an archaeologist, and her first encounter with the film and TV world was on a non-union, Prince video.
她周末最喜欢做的事情就是不设闹钟。啊，我太喜欢这些小贴士了。我也是。我希望这些对那些不认识这些人的人来说也会觉得有趣，但我就会想，哈，我喜欢能更深入地了解他们。我也很喜欢这些问题其实是有规律的。你会说几种语言？你去过哪个地方是让你爱不释手的？对啊。然后还有，你是什么时候第一次进入影视行业的？
Her favorite thing to do on the weekend is not set an alarm. Ah, I love these tips. I do too. I hope they're interesting to other people who don't know these people, but I'm like, huh, I love knowing, living in a little better. I also love that there's a pattern to the questions. How many languages do you speak? What's a place that you've been to that you love? Yeah. And then also, when did you first come to the film and TV industry?
以及你周末喜欢做什么？我很喜欢这种问题范围。这是一套非常棒的问题。也许我们应该把这些融入到我们的采访中。采访。采访。对啊。哦，记下了。我觉得我们可以这么做。
And then what do you like to do on the weekend? I like this range of questions. It's a really good set of questions. Maybe we should be incorporating these into our interviews. Interviews. Interviews. Yes. Oh, noted. I think we do it.
吉姆和潘被这场婚礼深深震撼了。我是说，这演技太绝了。是的。当罗伊开始弹钢琴唱歌时，潘就想：什么情况？这条故事线的全部意义所在，说实话，说到数字杂乱，我把罗伊的婚礼放进了我的电子邮件里，
Jim and Pam are shook up by the wedding. I mean, talk about mouth a game. Yes. When Roy starts playing the piano and singing, Pam is like, what? The whole point of this storyline, and it's interesting because talk about digital clutter, I put Roy's wedding into my email
因为我在寻找来自史蒂夫·伯吉斯的边角料，结果我找到了我和格雷格、艾莉森·西尔弗曼以及约翰·克拉辛斯基之间的那些旧邮件，当时我们正在碰撞各种不同的想法。而这个想法——即吉姆和潘会不知怎么地偶遇罗伊，而罗伊在离开潘的这段时间里已经变得更好了、成长了——这真的非常重要，因为这理所当然应该进一步突显吉姆和潘是多么原地踏步。突显成长似乎与他们无缘。不仅如此，还突显了他们之间的脱节。罗伊和劳拉看起来心有灵犀。
because I was looking for tidbits from Steve Burges, and I found these old emails between me, Greg, Allison Silverman, and John Krasinski, where we were pitching different ideas. And this idea that somehow Jim and Pam would run into Roy and he would have bettered himself like that he had grown in his time away from Pam. This was really important because it was supposed to of course further highlight how the same Jim and Pam are. How like growth seems to have alluded them. Not only that, but how they're disconnected. Roy and Laura seem very connected.
因为我在寻找史蒂夫·伯ges的趣闻碎事，我找到了我和格雷格、艾莉森·西尔弗曼以及约翰·卡拉辛斯基之间的这些旧电子邮件，当时我们正在构思不同的点子。这个点子是，吉姆和帕姆不知怎么地遇到了罗伊，而他已经变得更好了，就像他在离开帕姆的时间里有所成长一样。这真的很重要，因为它当然是为了进一步突显吉姆和帕姆是多么地一成不变。他们似乎如何都无法成长。不仅如此，还突显了他们是如何脱节的。罗伊和劳拉看起来非常心有灵犀。
Yes. I do want to point out one thing in the car, which I find curious, at nine minutes and 24 seconds, you can see C.C.'s car seat in the car makes sense. These things live in a car, but also Phillips pumpkin seat. Usually you leave the pumpkin seat at home, right? It just clicks into the base. Yeah. That's how we did it. We had a base in each car, but the pumpkin seat goes outside. Yeah. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It's very excited. It Pam's car. That's right. Well, you know this car scene Pam is going to ask Jim to tell her something she doesn't
是的。我确实想指出车里的一个细节，我觉得挺好奇的，在9分24秒时，你能看到C.C.的安全座椅在车里，这很合理。这些东西本来就该在车里，但还有菲利普的提篮式安全座椅。通常你不会把提篮留在车里，对吧？它只是卡在底座上。对。我们就是这样的。我们每个车里都有一个底座，但提篮是要拿出来的。对。帕姆的车。没错。好吧，你知道在这场车戏里，帕姆要让吉姆告诉她一些她不知道的
know about him. There was more to this moment, it's in deleted scenes and I want you to hear how this conversation ended. Oh, the record I like knowing everything about you. It's nice. Totally agree. We know each other inside now. No surprises.
关于他的事。这一段其实还有更多内容，在删减片段里，我想让你们听听这段对话是怎么结束的。哦，老实说，我喜欢了解关于你的一切。这很好。完全同意。我们对彼此了如指掌。没有惊喜。
Yeah, she says no surprises. And then his phone starts to buzz. And he doesn't answer it. He clicks, you know how you can kind of like make it stop buzzing. And then they just ride in silence. The moment was heavy, it was thick. I've been rewatching Breaking Bad. You have from the beginning. Okay.
对，她说没有惊喜。然后他的电话开始震动。而他没有接。他按了一下，你知道你可以让它停止震动那种操作。然后他们就在一片沉默中开车。当时的气氛很沉重，很凝滞。我一直在重温《绝命毒师》。你从头开始看的吗？好吧。
I had this theory that Breaking Bad is the best pilot ever made. And you know, I got sick a couple weeks ago. I was laid up for like two weeks. And I was like, for like two weeks, and I was like, what am I gonna watch? I spent two days watching Lawn Order reruns, and I was like, I think I need something with like more of an arc.
我有个理论，觉得《绝命毒师》拥有史上最棒的试播集。你知道的，我几周前生病了。我卧床休息了大约两周。然后我想，我想看点什么呢？我花了两天时间看《法律与秩序》的重播，然后我想，我觉得我需要看一部剧情更有起伏的作品。
You needed a break from gung, gung, yeah. So I was like, I'm gonna see. Is breaking bad the best pilot ever made? It is. It's incredible. Then I got hooked. Now I'm all the way almost at the end of season three, but you know, a big plot line is Walter White
你需要从那种枪战片里喘口气，对，枪战，对。所以我当时就想，我要看看。《绝命毒师》是不是史上最棒的试播集？确实是。太不可思议了。然后我就入坑了。现在我几乎快看完第三季了，不过你知道，里面有个很大的剧情线是沃尔特·怀特
and his burner phone. Yeah. And it's always buzzing. Yeah. In those early seasons and his wife is like, what's going on? What's up with the second cell phone? Yeah.
和他的 burner 手机（一次性手机）。对。而且它总是在震动。对。在前几季里，他老婆就问：怎么回事？第二部手机是怎么回事？对。
The second cell phone. Mmm. Are the calls you're not taking in your partner's presence? Listen, all that says it all. If the phone is ringing and they purposely don't answer it, who's on the other end of that call? That's right. You're either having an affair or you're making meth or you have started a business with your friend and you're not telling your wife.
第二部手机。嗯。是不是那些你在伴侣面前不敢接的电话？听着，这一切都说明问题了。如果电话在响，而他们故意不接，那电话那头会是谁？没错。要么你是在偷情，要么你在制毒，要么你和朋友合伙开公司却没告诉你老婆。
Those are the three things. Back at Dundra Mifflin in the kitchen, Jim and Pam are still continuing this, like tell me something I don't know about you. And then Jim's like, oh, remember the story about how my brothers tricked me into thinking they won the lottery, but Pam already knew that one. And then Angela Bragg's that the senator is always surprising her.
这就是三种可能。镜头回到邓德米夫林的厨房，吉姆和帕姆还在继续这个游戏，比如“告诉我一些我不知道的关于你的事”。然后吉姆就说：“哦，还记得我哥哥们恶作剧骗我说他们中了彩票的那件事吗？”但帕姆早就知道了。接着安吉拉吹嘘说参议员总是给她惊喜。
I thought Oscar did such a great job in that moment. I had to mimic it because I was like, that was so good. I thought it was so good how he just kept choking down his coffee. It was such good acting. I loved it. Have you ever played this game with Josh, where you say, like, tell me something I don't know about you? Have you ever played this game? No, where you say, like, tell me something I don't know about you? Have you ever played this game? No, because Josh doesn't want to know.
我觉得奥斯卡在那段戏里表现得太棒了。我不得不模仿一下，因为我觉得太精彩了。我觉得他一直强忍着往下咽咖啡的样子演得太好了，演技真好，我太喜欢了。你有没有和乔希玩过这个游戏，就是对对方说：“告诉我一些我不知道的关于你的事”？你玩过这个游戏吗？没有，因为乔希不想知道。
He doesn't want to know things he doesn't already know about you. Yeah. This is very funny. Yeah, he's just like, I don't need to know anything about past relationships. I just need to live in the here and now with you. Lee and I like to play this game sometimes. If we have a date night, we'll be like, like okay we're not allowed to talk about the kids, we're not allowed to talk about school emails, right, right, or any house improvements or any chores
他不想知道那些关于你、他还不知道的事情。对。这太搞笑了。对，他大概觉得：我不需要了解你过去的感情经历。我只需要和你活在当下。我和莉丝有时候喜欢玩这个游戏。如果我们有个约会之夜，我们会说：好吧，我们不能聊孩子，不能聊学校的邮件，对，对，或者任何房屋装修或家务活
no schedule. Let's be adults together. So I'll say tell me a story I've never heard before. Yeah. And it it often ends up being something rather interesting. I have to say it's a fun little game. It's not working for Jim and Pam, though. Well, Nelly is going to approach Dwight now. Nelly says, look, if you support the Taliban abroad, you have to be willing to live by their rules here. And she wants that in writing,
没有时间表。让我们一起像成年人一样相处。所以我就会说：给我讲一个我从来没听过的故事。对。而它往往会变成一件相当有趣的事情。我必须说这是一个挺有趣的小游戏。不过这招对吉姆和帕姆不管用。好吧，尼莉现在要去找德怀特了。尼莉说：听着，如果你在海外支持塔利班，那你也得愿意在这里遵守他们的规矩。她要把这个写成书面协议，
and she hands him a contract, which he signs willingly. Dwight then has a talking head where he says, he feared Nelly had a plan, but the ridiculous font tells him otherwise. Then it cuts to Nelly's talking head and she says, when you use a ridiculous font, no one thinks you have a plan. Well, this made me curious about fonts. Oh! I went online in according to 99designs.com. Here's what makes a good font. Oh! Okay. Even kerning?
她递给他一份合同，而他欣然签字了。接着德怀特有一个独白镜头，他说他担心尼莉有什么阴谋，但那荒谬的字体告诉他并没有。然后画面切到尼莉的独白，她说：当你使用荒谬的字体时，没人会觉得你有什么阴谋。好吧，这让我对字体产生了好奇。哦！我上网查了一下，根据 99designs.com 的说法，以下是好字体的标准。哦！好吧。连字间距（Kerning）也要均匀吗？
What's a kern? Exactly. What is kerning? Kerning is the space between two characters. Two little space and the font is unreadable because the letters are smushed together. Too much space and it's hard to tell whether the space is meant to separate letters or words. Oh, that's the Kern. Even Kurning. The Kern is the space between... The Space.
什么是字间距？没错。什么是字间距？字间距就是两个字符之间的空间。间距太小，字体就会变得难以辨认，因为字母都挤成一团了。间距太大，又很难分清这个空格到底是用来隔开字母还是单词的。哦，这就是字间距。连字间距都要均匀。字间距就是……空间之间的距离。
Oh, I want to use that. I want to like look at someone's handwriting and say, oh, you have beautiful Kurning. Yes. The next one is consistency. For example, Futura and Helvechia are two examples of fonts that are easy to read because of their kerning and the consistency of the letters. Okay. And if you're wondering what consistency means, it means like, if you have a font for the letter A and that has serifs, you expect the letter B to have serifs too and so on from there. If you're wondering what a serif is.
哦，我想用这个词。我想看着别人的笔迹说：“哦，你的字间距真好看。”是的。下一个标准是一致性。例如，Futura 和 Helvetica 就是两个很好的例子，它们因为字间距以及字母的一致性而非常易读。好的。如果你想知道一致性是什么意思，它的意思是：如果你字母 A 的字体带有衬线（serif），那你也会期望字母 B 也有衬线，以此类推。如果你想知道什么是衬线。
A serif is the marker line that can sometimes appear at the end of a character's stroke. Ah, I think I'm picturing a serif. Okay. Then you want balance. You want a blend of thick and thin, heavy and light. That's another component of a good font. And lastly, it must be legible. I have a question for you. Yes. Do you have a favorite font? I like the sand syrup typefaces. You know? I think the one I use the most is maybe Verdana. What about you?
衬线就是有时会出现在字符笔画末端的装饰线条。啊，我想我脑海中大概有衬线的画面了。好的。接下来你需要的是平衡感。你需要粗细、轻重之间的完美结合。这是好字体的另一个要素。最后，它必须清晰易读。我有个问题要问你。好的。你有什么最喜欢的字体吗？我比较喜欢无衬线字体。你知道吗？我想我用得最多的可能是 Verdana 吧。你呢？
Well, for a very long time, I was a Times New Roman. That is on the list of worst fonts. I have moved to Calibri. Calibri's good. That's when my document is printed in right now. It's printed in Calibri 18. I also like Calibri too. That is also a sans-serif font.
嗯，在很长一段时间里，我都是个 Times New Roman（新罗马字体）的忠实拥趸。那个可是被列入最烂字体名单的。我已经换成 Calibri 了。Calibri 挺好的。我现在的文档就是用这个打印的。是用 18 号 Calibri 打印的。我也挺喜欢 Calibri 的。那也是一款无衬线字体。
It is? Yes. Oh. What is sans means without in French? So what is Serif? What is it without? A theme with sans serif typepaces are they're very clean and minimal. They look a little bit more modern. If a font has a Serif, it has like the finishing of a stroke. You know what's a font that uses Serif's is times New Roman. Oh, yeah. Okay.
是吗？是的。哦。Sans 在法语里是什么意思？是“没有”的意思。那 Serif 是什么？它没有的是什么？无衬线字体的特点是它们非常干净且极简。它们看起来更现代一些。如果一个字体有 Serif，它就会有类似笔画收尾的装饰。你知道哪款字体用了 Serif 吗？就是 Times New Roman。哦，对。好吧。
Also, this website said Garamond is a good one. Oh, I've used it before, but. And according to several websites, I mean, this one made the list on many websites. One of the most horrible fonts is Joker Men. I have to look at it. I'm so sorry. I can put it in stories too. I need to see it.
另外，这个网站说 Garamond 是一款不错的字体。哦，我以前用过，但是……而且根据几个网站的说法——我是说，这款字体上了很多网站的黑榜——其中最糟糕的字体之一就是 Jokerman。我得去看看它长什么样。真是不好意思。我也可以发到动态里。我得亲眼瞧瞧。
Oh! Oh! It's horrible! It looks like... Oh! This looks like what Nelly used. It's awful. It looks like the letters have a disease. It's so busy. Doesn't it? It's so busy. Yeah. It looks like a plant, the Venus fly trap. If you took a Venus fly trap and turned it into letters, that's what this looks like. Yes to me. Yes.
哦！天哪！太糟糕了！它看起来像……哦！这看起来像是尼莉用过的字体。太可怕了。它看起来就像字母生了病一样。花里胡哨的。不是吗？花里胡哨的。对。它看起来像一种植物，比如维纳斯捕蝇草。如果你把维纳斯捕蝇草变成字母，就是长这样。确实。我觉得是。
Well, Joker Man is not popular. I'm so sorry to the person who invented the Jokerman font. Sorry, sorry. You tried hard, but I think you wanted to edit. You did too much. Yeah. Take one thing away. Our three. Three things away. Angela, that was all very interesting. You know, I found it so interesting, just the science behind how we relate to the written characters. The door that's opening for me now is who invents fonts and how do you get them like widely used? Who's doing it?
好吧，Jokerman 并不受欢迎。真替发明 Jokerman 字体的那个人感到抱歉。抱歉，抱歉。你尽力了，但我猜你当时很想做修改。你用力过猛了。删掉一个元素。不对，删掉三个元素。安吉拉，刚才这些都太有趣了。你知道的，我觉得这太有意思了，仅仅是我们与书面字符产生联系背后的科学原理。现在为我打开的一扇新门是：到底是谁在发明字体？你又是怎么让它们得到广泛使用的？谁在干这行？
What is the font industry? Yeah. How do you get paid for that? Who comes up with this list about even kerning? Yeah, that's gonna keep me up at night now. Sorry. Sorry, that's all right. Let's see, next up, Andy is gonna get word of this newscaster audition. And he has some strong feelings about it.
字体行业到底是怎样的？对。你怎么能靠这个赚钱？是谁搞出了关于连字间距均匀的这个标准的？对，这下今晚要让我睡不着觉了。抱歉。抱歉，没关系。好啦，接下来，安迪将听到关于这次新闻主播试镜的消息。对此他有着强烈的感受。
He's gonna storm into the Annex and confront Clark, he's gonna say, what is this that I hear about you wanting to film Aaron in various outfits in your apartment. My big question is, what specific outfits does she need? Oh, Andy. He buys into it too. What an idiot.
他要冲进附楼质问克拉克，他会说：我听说你想在公寓里让艾琳穿各种不同的服装进行拍摄，这到底是怎么回事？我最大的问题是，她具体需要穿哪些服装？哦，安迪。他居然也信了这一套。真是个白痴。
Also, at 13 minutes and 23 seconds, this has probably been there the whole episode, but it's when I finally noticed that Andy has a grappling hook on his pants. Oh, the thing that like if you're climbing a mountain, you have to put the thing. He's got that hanging off his pants and also he started wearing these puffy vest coats. This is all from his outward bound experience. Yes. Yes.
还有，在13分23秒时——这个细节可能整集都有，但我直到这时才注意到——安迪的裤子上挂着一个登山扣。哦，就是那种如果你去爬山必须用到的东西。他把那玩意儿挂在裤子上，而且他还开始穿这种膨胀羽绒马衣。这全都是他参加户外拓展（Outward Bound）经历的产物。没错了。对。
He's ready to climb if needed. Yep. I also wanted to point out in this scene at 13 minutes and 32 seconds, Pete is eating a container of baby carrots just like Jim always does. Maybe he is Jim Jr. Well in the kitchen, a few folks have gathered around. Jim and Pam are basically playing the newlywed game. Kevin wants a lot of personal questions and angels like no. Toby knows all of Pam's answers. Pam's first celebrity crush, John Stamos. And then it moved quickly to Johnny Depp, which Toby also knew.
如果有需要的话，他随时准备去攀岩。没错。我还想指出在这场戏中，在13分32秒时，皮特正在吃一盒婴儿胡萝卜，就像吉姆总是做的那样。也许他就是小吉姆吧。好吧，在厨房里，几个人聚在了一起。吉姆和帕姆基本上在玩新婚夫妇问答游戏。凯文想问很多私密问题，而安吉拉则是一脸“休想”的表情。托比知道帕姆所有的答案。帕姆的第一个名流暗恋对象是约翰·斯塔莫斯。然后迅速变成了约翰尼·德普，托比也知道这一点。
And then he says, sorry, I was having a separate conversation with Kevin. And then Kevin at the end says, what's the craziest place you ever made? Whoopi, he brings this question back. This is his question. Yeah. And Angela says, Kevin, stop it with that question.
然后他说：抱歉，我刚刚在和凯文聊别的事。然后凯文在最后说：你们做过……最疯狂的地方是哪里？他又把这个问题给扯回来了。这是他的问题。对。然后安吉拉说：凯文，别再问这种问题了。
That was improvised. That last couple of Kevin isn't supposed to bring it back. Angel isn't supposed to say anything. But we just kept going. They let the cameras roll. We just kept going. When I was watching the scene, it made me remember that when I was younger, before I ever moved to LA, growing up, I had two really big celebrity crushes. Okay. Like posters on my wall, buying the team beat magazines. Yeah. Huge.
那是即兴发挥。最后那几句里，凯文本来不应该把话题扯回去的。安吉拉本来也不应该说什么的。但我们就是顺着演下去了。他们让摄像机一直开着。我们就这么演了下去。当我看到这一幕时，让我想起了我年轻的时候，在我搬到洛杉矶之前，在成长过程中，我有两个超级大牌的名人暗恋对象。好吧。比如把海报贴在墙上，买《16》岁杂志那种。对。超级喜欢。
Huge, I never had a celebrity poster on my wall. Really? Never. Okay, I did. And when I got to LA, early in my acting career, I got cast in movies with both of my celebrity crushes. Can you share who they are? I will not share who they are.
超级喜欢，我的墙上从来没有贴过名人的海报。真的吗？从来没有。好吧，我有。当我到了洛杉矶，在演艺生涯早期，我参演的电影里刚好有我的两个名流暗恋对象。你能分享一下他们是谁吗？我才不分享他们是谁呢。
What? Because. You gotta listen out there and then not tell us? Because when I met them in real life, I was disappointed. I was not disappointed, but I was in no way attracted to them at all. Like, I couldn't believe it.
什么？因为。你得在外面听着，然后却不告诉我们？因为当我真人在现实中遇到他们时，我很失望。倒也不是失望，而是我压根对他们一点感觉都没有了。真的，我简直不敢相信。
I was like, how is this possible? Like, nothing. Like, dead inside. Didn't find them hot. Didn't get any butterflies. Couldn't have been less interested. I found it so fascinating. It happened twice.
我当时就想：这怎么可能？就完全没感觉。像内心已经死寂了一样。觉得他们一点都不性感。完全没有心动的感觉。不可能再比这更不感兴趣了。我觉得这太神奇了。竟然发生了两次。
Wow. Twice. It wasn't that they were any less good looking or whatever, but it was just nothing. Huh. I mean, I guess my only real true celebrity crush has been Kiana Reeves. He's never been on a poster in my room,
哇。两次。倒不是说他们长得不帅了或者别的什么，但就是一点感觉都没有。哈。我的意思，我猜我唯一真正称得上名流暗恋对象的只有基努·里维斯。我的房间里从来没有贴过他的海报，
but he is on a coffee mug I have. But you've never met him in real life. No, but remember I had that moment where my friend Wyatt said that Kiana was on a motorcycle and checked out my... Yeah, that's right. And I'm gonna hold on to that forever, whether it was really Kiana or not. Someone on a motorcycle checked out your touch. And that was 20 years ago, but I'm gonna hold on to it.
但我有一个印着他的马克杯。但你从来没在现实中见过他。没有，但还记得我有一次，我的朋友怀亚特说基努骑着摩托车，还回头打量了我……对，没错。不管那到底是不是基努，我都要把这个回忆永远记在心里。有个骑摩托车的人打量了你的臀部。那是20年前的事了，但我会一直记着。
Hold on to it. Yeah. Even if it was just a stranger on a motorcycle, you're holding that dear. Somebody took a double take. Well, during this scene, Jim is gonna get another phone call and he's gonna excuse himself. Yeah.
一直记着。对。哪怕那只是个骑摩托车的陌生人，你也把这当成宝贝。有人回头看了你第二眼。好吧，在这场戏中，吉姆接到了另一个电话，他找了个借口走开了。对。
Wow. And then he has a talking head where he says, you know what, I'm not going to tell her till it's real. And Pam has a talking head where she says maybe there is something I don't know about Jim. I think this is a good time to talk about our friend Miles McNut because he had a lot of thoughts on this storyline. Oh, we haven't heard from Miles in a bit.
哇。然后他有一个独白镜头，他说：你知道吗，在一切成为现实之前，我不打算告诉她。而帕姆有一个独白镜头，她说：也许真的有什么事是我不知道的，关于吉姆的。我觉得现在是个好时机来聊聊我们的朋友迈尔斯·麦克纳特（Miles McNutt），因为他对这条剧情线有很多想法。哦，我们有一阵子没听到迈尔斯的动态了。
I can't wait. I live for our Miles McNut reviews. Well, Miles actually stopped writing reviews for the office at the end of season eight, but the new reviewer was out this week, the week of Roy's wedding. So Miles wrote this review. This was his final review of the office. He gave this episode to be, and he reviewed this episode, but he also kind of gave some thoughts about the new direction of season 9, which he was liking very much. For example, he loves Jerk Andy. Okay, he liked that change.
我等不及了。我活着就是为了看迈尔斯·麦克纳特的剧评。好吧，迈尔斯其实在第八季末就停止为《办公室》撰写剧评了，但本周——也就是罗伊婚礼的那周——新剧评人出炉了。所以迈尔斯写了这篇评论。这是他对《办公室》的最后一篇剧评。他给这集的评价是 B，他不仅评论了这一集，还对第九季的新走向发表了一些看法，他非常喜欢这个新走向。例如，他喜欢混蛋安迪。好吧，他喜欢这个转变。
He likes the addition of Clark and Pete, and he loved the Jim Pamp storyline. Here's what he said, quote, it's the couple's strongest storyline in a long time, and it's also giving the show the kind of arc structure that it lacked last season. Heck, it's even retroactively giving last season meaning, with Jim and Pam's boring storylines now becoming a period within their larger arc, which was underserved and often outright ignored in season eight,
他喜欢加入克拉克和皮特，而且他非常喜欢吉姆和帕姆的剧情线。他是这么说的，引述如下：“这是这对情侣很长一段时间以来最强的剧情线，这也为剧集提供了上季所缺乏的那种剧情起伏结构。甚至，它还在某种程度上赋予了上一季现实意义，吉姆和帕姆那些原本无聊的剧情线现在成了他们宏大故事弧光中的一个阶段，虽然在第八季中这个阶段没有得到充分展现，甚至经常被彻底忽视，”
which I actually thought was such a good point. We barely checked in on Jim and Pam's relationship in season eight, and now this idea that their relationship was too boring to check in on is becoming a major story point. So genius of Greg to think of this. He went on to say, no matter how cynical I might be about other parts of the show, I am too invested in Jim and Pam's characters to not respond
我觉得这个观点真的太棒了。我们在第八季里几乎没怎么关注吉姆和帕姆的关系，而现在，他们以前的关系因为“太无聊而不值得关注”反而成了主线剧情。格雷格能想到这一点简直太天才了。他接着写道：“无论我对剧集的其他部分有多么愤世嫉俗，我对吉姆和帕姆这两个角色投入了太多的感情，无法对这种新的角色塑造无动于衷，这种塑造提出了过去几年里剧集似乎不敢去问的重大问题。作为一个比其他人更关注剧集戏剧性一面的剧评人，吉姆决定对新工作保密，以及这条剧情线中所蕴含的反思与回顾特质，带来了自史蒂夫·卡瑞尔离开以来我对这部剧最强烈的情感共鸣。”哇。
to this new characterization, one that asked big questions the show seemed too chicken to ask over the past few years. And as a reviewer who has always been more invested in the dramatic side of the show than others, Jim's decision to keep his new job a secret and the introspective and retrospective qualities of the storyline are resulting in the strongest emotional connection I've felt with the show since Steve Carell's departure. Wow.
哇。
I think that I had to read that because I'm really, really proud because John and I got to be a part of crafting this. And Greg really listened to us. And we wanted all the things that he just said to land on the audience. So I was so happy. Also, Miles is such a good writer. Can we just say that? I know. Everything he wrote there, I was like, yes! I know. I kind of opened up to how I'm looking at the season now. I felt so seen when I read it.
我觉得我必须把这段读出来，因为我真的、真的很骄傲，因为乔恩和我参与了塑造这个过程。格雷格真的听取了我们的意见。我们希望他刚才说的所有感受都能传递给观众。所以我太开心了。另外，迈尔斯真的是个很好的写手。我们能夸一下吗？我知道。他写的所有东西，我都觉得：太对了！我知道。这甚至让我对这一季的看法有了新的转变。当我读到这些时，觉得自己的心声被深刻理解了。
And then also Miles signed off in this way. He said, and Ernest, thank you to everyone who has read or commented on my review of the show over the past two years. It's been incredibly rewarding and enjoyable to go head to head about a show that people connect with so personally and have strong opinions about. And I'll admit that I'll likely be dropping in and out of the comments as the season goes on. However, I do so not as a critic but as a viewer. So do feel free to insult my person as you would any other commenter with whom you strongly disagree.
而且最后迈尔斯是这样结尾的。他说：“最后，真心感谢过去两年里阅读或评论我该剧剧评的每一个人。能够与那些对这部剧有着深刻共鸣、有着强烈观点的人进行正面交流，是非常有意义且享受的。我承认，随着新的一季推进，我可能会偶尔在评论区露面。不过，我来的时候不是作为一个剧评人，而是作为一个普通观众。所以，你们完全可以像对待任何其他你们强烈不同意的评论员一样，来人身攻击我，这很公平。”
It's only fair. Miles, we're going to miss your reviews. Yes, miles. You have made this rewatch so enjoyable. I've loved your insight and your thoughts. I'm sad that we won't have any of your reviews for Dwight and Angela's. I know. Rekindling. And and I would have loved to see your reviews on the Senator and Oscar. Yes, Angela, that storyline is not in this episode and he didn't comment on it, but I have to believe that he loved it as much as we do. Or would have had some very interesting thoughts. I welcome either. Maybe I'll have to check the comments as we go along.
这很公平。迈尔斯，我们会想念你的剧评的。是的，迈尔斯。你让这次重播观影变得如此享受。我太喜欢你的见解和想法了。我很遗憾在德怀特和安吉拉重修旧好的部分里再也看不到你的剧评了。我知道。而且我本很希望能看到你对参议员和奥斯卡的评论。是的，安吉拉，那一集里没有这条剧情线，他也没有对此发表评论，但我相信他一定和我们一样喜欢这个情节。或者也会有一些非常有趣的看法。我都挺期待的。也许随着剧集的播出，我得去评论区看看了。
Oh, yes. Miles, we might look for you in the comments. Yep. See, if Miles is there and Steve B. Yeah, that's right. Steve B, aka Steve Burgess. Or so we think. Defending the show.
哦，是的。迈尔斯，我们可能会在评论区搜寻你的身影。没错。瞧瞧迈尔斯在不在，还有史蒂夫·B。对，没错。史蒂夫·B，也就是史蒂夫·伯吉斯。或者我们以为是他。在为剧集辩护呢。
Well now, Darryl and Andy are gonna call a voluntary meeting in the conference room to discuss Aaron's confidence, but also like her body. Well, basically her outward appearance. Because once again, I guess in order to be a newscaster, it's all about your looks, it doesn't matter about your journalism degree.
现在呢，达里尔和安迪要在会议室召开一次自愿参加的会议，讨论艾琳的自信心，同时也讨论她的身材。好吧，基本上就是她的外表。因为又一次，我猜为了当新闻主播，一切都取决于你的外表，你的新闻学位根本不重要。
Or not for this news job. That's right. We also are going to learn in a Darrell talking head that he has become Andy's conciliary or also known as the Assistant Regional Manager. Yeah. So I want you guys to know, Darryl is going to be part of several scenes with Andy and Aaron as they figure out how she's going to be a news anchor.
或者至少这份新闻工作是这样的。没错。我们在达里尔的独白中还将了解到，他已经成了安迪的“军师”（Consigliere），也就是助理地区经理。对。所以我想让你们知道，达里尔接下来会和安迪、艾琳一起出现在好几场戏里，因为他们要想方设法帮她成为新闻主播。
There's a bunch of deleted scenes, too. I'll share them when they come up. Well, when this conference room begins, there's an interesting moment. We got a fan question about it from Kaylee F. in Hawaii. I hope I'm pronouncing your name correctly. Who said Angela? What are you saying to Oscar in the conference room when Andy Reveals Aaron's pursuit of an anchor person audition? It seems a little out of character that you're just chatting with your friend. He's such a great catch. So in the shooting draft, Angela and Oscar had a lot of back and forth comments about Aaron being a news anchor and they seemed to have really bond over being judgy about it.
还有一堆被删减的片段呢。等它们出现时我会分享的。好吧，当这个会议室的会议开始时，有一个有趣的时刻。我们收到了来自夏威夷的凯莉·F. 发来的粉丝提问。希望我没有把你的名字念错。她问：“安吉拉？当安迪透露艾琳要去试镜主播时，你在会议室里对奥斯卡说了什么？你俩就在那儿闲聊，感觉有点不太符合你的人设。他真是一个不错的结婚对象。”所以在拍摄剧本中，安吉拉和奥斯卡针对艾琳当新闻主播这件事有很多来回的对话，他们似乎因为一起对此评头论足而真正建立起了某种羁绊。
Some of it may deleted scenes, let's hear it. Does everyone have any experience? Has she taken any journalism classes, maybe? Has she done the pageant circuit? No, I watched this. She's going to be amazing. Look at her. She's going to light up the screen. Does she even want to do it? Of course she wants to do it. She's gonna be amazing. Look at her. She's gonna light up the screen. Does she even wanna do it? Of course she wants to do it.
有些内容可能是删减片段，我们来听听看。大家都有经验吗？她上过新闻类的课程吗？她参加过选美比赛吗？没有，我看了这个。她一定会大放异彩的。看着她。她会把整个屏幕都点亮的。她自己甚至想去吗？她当然想去。她一定会大放异彩的。看着她。她会把整个屏幕都点亮的。她自己甚至想去吗？她当然想去。
She answers phones. It's not fair, Angela. Some people don't aspire for anything higher than that's just fine for sure. Hey, over here. So what happens is when they were trimming the scene, some of this back and forth got trimmed, but the end of it is there where Oscar and I
她只是接电话的。这不公平，安吉拉。有些人不追求比这更高的目标，那也完全没问题。嘿，看这边。所以情况是这样的，当时在精简这场戏时，一些来回对话被剪掉了，但结尾部分还在，我和奥斯卡
are kind of leaning over and he's like, Agile, that's not fair. I'm like, okay, fine. Well, if you say so. And we're having our little hub hub hub hub. Okay. And then Aaron is meant to interrupt us and say, hey, over here, I want to do this.
凑过去，他说：“安吉拉，这不公平。”我说：“好吧，行吧。随你便咯。”我们在那儿嘀嘀咕咕、窃窃私语。然后艾琳本该打断我们说：“嘿，看这边，我想做这个。”
So you're catching us having this little hub hub. But Oscar and I were such long time friends. We had met years before the office. I've shared this We had performed in sketch comedy together We were so giddy about having any kind of storyline together and and and this season in particular we get to have a lot So a lot of that I do think you see the friendship that's there that maybe Angela and Oscar didn't have to the extent that we hadn't real life. Andy is now going to ask everyone to name something they like about
所以你们看到的是我们在这儿嘀咕的片段。但我和奥斯卡是多年老友了。我们在《办公室》之前很多年就认识了。我分享过这件事，我们曾一起表演过即兴滑稽短剧。能有任何形式的共同剧情线让我们感到非常兴奋，尤其是这一季里我们有了很多这样的对手戏。所以很多地方，你确实能看出那种真实存在的友谊，也许安吉拉和奥斯卡之间在现实中并没有达到那种程度。安迪现在要让每个人说出一样他们喜欢的
Aaron's body so that she can feel more confident about her audition. Darryl says he likes her hair. Andy says that attractive people appear more trustworthy and Oscar is going to object and kind of bring up Walter Cronkite's reign as the most trusted man in America. And then Meredith is gonna say, she thought Walter Cronkite was hot and would take that mustache ride. Go to 15 minutes and 56 seconds. What will I see?
艾琳身体的部位，好让她对试镜更有自信。达里尔说他喜欢她的头发。安迪说有吸引力的人显得更值得信赖，而奥斯卡则反驳了他，并顺势提到了沃尔特·克朗凯特作为“全美最值得信赖的人”的统治地位。然后梅雷迪思说，她觉得沃尔特·克朗凯特很性感，甚至愿意坐一回他的“胡子过山车”（take that mustache ride）。快进到15分56秒。我能看到什么？
You will see Angela Martin making a face, Jim making a face, and Creed looking inquisitive slash making a face. I took a screen grab of it, I'll put it in stories. I love it. Erin is going to do a mock reading for Daryl and Andy. She has written her news copy and it doesn't make any sense. But the thing that they are going to give her a note about is how long she pauses between saying for Channel 11 news? I'm Erin Hannon. No longer pause, even longer.
你会看到安吉拉·马丁做了一个鬼脸，吉姆做了一个鬼脸，而克里德则是一副好奇的表情外加做了一个鬼脸。我截了图，会发到动态里。我太喜欢了。艾琳要为达里尔和安迪进行一次模拟播报。她自己写了新闻稿，根本不通顺。但他们要给她的反馈意见却是她在说“这里是11频道新闻，我是艾琳·汉农”之间停顿的时间有多长。不要停顿那么久，停顿得更久一点。
It's going to build suspense, don't be shy. There are more scenes of Andy working with Erin while Darryl, poor Darryl has to sit there and watch this. Here's one I need you to hear. But I'm really bad at public speaking. Don't think of it as public speaking. Think of it as music. The news is music.
这样才能制造悬念，别害羞。还有更多安迪指导艾琳的戏份，而可怜的达里尔只能坐在旁边看着这一切。这段对话你们一定要听听。但我很不擅长公开演讲。不要把它当成公开演讲。把它当成音乐。新闻就是音乐。
You sing it. Momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, good, good, good, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, momoma, MMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMM Mom, mom, you're welcome. I have to say there is a melody to the way newscasters speak. Yes. And this is reminding me of something I saw on Instagram. It's this husband and he goes up to his newscaster wife and he's like, babe, how do you say I told you so in news speak? And then she thanks for a second and then she does it.
你把它唱出来。Momoma, momoma, momoma……好，很好，很好……（省略重复拟声词）……不客气。我必须说，新闻主播说话的方式确实有一种旋律感。是的。这让我想起了我在 Instagram 上看到的一个视频。有个丈夫走到他当新闻主播的妻子面前说：“宝贝，用新闻腔怎么说‘我早就告诉过你了’？”然后她思考了一会儿，就用新闻腔说出来了。
It's so fun. Will you give me a second to find it? Yeah. Hey babe. Yeah. How do you say I told you so in the anchor boys? Good evening. Your time now is on 52 on Jeanette Reyes.
太好玩了。能给我几秒钟找找吗？好的。嘿，宝贝。怎么了？在主播界里怎么说“我早就告诉过你了”？晚上好。现在是 52 分，我是珍妮特·雷耶斯。
This just into our newsroom. It did not take experts to project that this would be the outcome. In fact, this gentleman's wife told him on multiple occasions, will it happen again? You betcha. That's great. Isn't that funny? There's a whole bunch, but I do hear the mama mama mama mama mama mama mama. Yeah. In this deleted scene to the other part of it that you can't see on the podcast is the whole time Andy and Erin are like, momma, momma, momma, momma, Darrell is just sitting there like this pained expression. Ah, well, meanwhile, I think we should mention that after
本台刚刚收到消息。专家们根本不用预测就知道会是这个结果。事实上，这位先生的妻子曾多次提醒过他，这种情况还会再次发生吗？那是肯定的。太棒了。是不是很有趣？这里还有一大堆，但我确实能听到 moma moma moma……对。在这段删减片段里，在播客里看不到的另一部分是，在安迪和艾琳一直在“moma moma moma”的整个过程中，达里尔就坐在那里，脸上带着一种痛苦的表情。啊，与此同时，我觉得我们应该提一下，在
signing this Taliban contract in the silly font, Nelly has stolen Dwight's pen, the consequences for which are cutting off her hand. If Dwight believes in Taliban rule and she stole from him, then he's gonna need to cut off her hand. So they go to the break room and they're kind of having a standoff. Is he gonna chop off her hand or is he not? Yeah. I guess Darrell as the new Consulieri assistant regional manager, he's going to come and
签了那份用愚蠢字体写成的塔利班合同后，尼莉偷了德怀特的钢笔，而这么做的代价是砍掉她的手。如果德怀特信仰塔利班的规矩，而她又偷了他的东西，那他必须砍掉她的手。所以他们去了休息室，开始了一场对峙。他到底是要砍掉她的手，还是不砍？对。我猜达里尔作为新的“军师”助理地区经理，他会来
problem solve this moment. Yeah. Darrell brings his laptop in the break room. He says, you know what? I want you guys to watch this movie for inspiration. It's called 127 hours. And Dwight and Nelly reluctantly watch it. Do you know what this movie is about?
解决这个麻烦。对。达里尔把他的笔记本电脑拿进了休息室。他说：你知道吗？我想让你们看这部电影找找灵感。它叫《127小时》。然后德怀特和尼莉很不情愿地看了起来。你知道这部电影讲的是什么吗？
I couldn't remember. Yes, I do. Yeah. I could not remember what it was, and then I looked it up and I was like, oh yeah! It's based on a true story. Yes, it came out in 2010.
我记不清了。我知道，我知道。对。我记不起来是什么了，然后我查了一下，我就想：哦，对！它是根据真实故事改编的。是的，它是在2010年上映的。
It's a survivalist drama. I mean, that's right up my alley, right? It was co-written and directed by Danny Boyle, and it's based on the true story of Mountain Climber Aaron Ralston, who got trapped under a boulder for 127 hours. Yes, where he was trapped was his arm. Yes, I mean, spoiler alert.
这是一部求生主义题材的电影。我的天，这太对我的胃口了，对吧？它由丹尼·鲍尔联合编剧并执导，改编自登山者阿伦·拉斯顿的真实故事，他被困在一块巨石下长达127小时。对，被压住的部位是他的手臂。对，剧透警告。
In order to get out, he had to amputate his own arm, using the dull blade from a pocket knife. I mean, and then after that, he still had to crawl out and get to safety. Yeah, but it came down to, I'm gonna die here, because no one's gonna find me. Yeah, his phone didn't work. He's like underground. Sort of like in a car-
为了逃生，他不得不使用一把折叠小刀上那把钝了的刀刃，亲手截断自己的手臂。我的天，然后在那之后，他还得爬出来寻找救援。对，但情况已经到了“我得死在这里，因为根本没人会找到我”的地步。对，他的手机没有信号。他在地下。有点像在车里——
Like in a car- Yes, exactly. And so he had to like face this, my God, survival, moral dilemma of like, if I chop off my own arm and climb out of here, I have a chance of living, but if I don't, I die here. Did you ever read that Stephen King short story? It's in his book of short stories about the guy who gets trapped on an island and he starts slowly eating himself. No. Yeah, in order to stay alive, he's like, I'll just cut off my pinky finger and then I'll beat it. And that's like how he is staying alive.
像在车里——对，完全没错。所以他不得不面对这种——天哪——关于生存的道德困境：如果我自己砍断手臂从这里爬出去，我还有活下去的可能；但如果不这么做，我就会死在这里。你读过斯蒂芬·金的那篇短篇小说吗？收在他的短篇小说集里，讲的是一个家伙被困在一个荒岛上，然后他开始慢慢吃自己。没有。对，为了活下去，他想：我先把自己的小指切下来吃掉。然后这就是他维持生命的方式。
And he's like slowly amputating parts of himself for food. Oh God. Mm-hmm. Does he survive? I don't think he does. Oh God. Also, what happens is at a certain point, like, you get infections.
他就像这样慢慢切下自己身体的一部分来当食物。天哪。嗯。他最后活下来了吗？我觉得他没有。天哪。还有，发生的情况是，到了一定阶段，你会感染的。
No, he just like, he can't use his limbs anymore to cut because he's eaten them. I believe is what happened. Oh, Lord. I mean, I'm sure he also got infections. I think the story doesn't go there. Okay. Well, where are we? Well, they end up watching the whole movie. They seem to have enjoyed it. And their storyline ends with them accusing each other of being stupid. Yeah. And no hand-chopping occurs.
不，他只是——他再也没法用自己的四肢去割肉了，因为已经被他吃光了。我记得是这样。哦，天哪。我的意思是，我确信他也感染了。我觉得故事里没写到那一步。好吧。我们说到哪了？好吧，他们最后把整部电影看完了。他们似乎还挺喜欢的。而他们剧情线的结局是两人互相指责对方是个笨蛋。对。并没有发生砍手事件。
No. So I guess Darrell's distraction worked because they end up getting in an argument about the movie instead. Good job, Darrell. Way to go, Darrell. Meanwhile, Pam is still trying to find out what's up with Jim. She tries to tell him the story about running into an old friend who flirted with her,
没有。所以我想达里尔的转移视线策略成功了，因为他们最后转而为电影本身争论起来了。干得好，达里尔。真有你的，达里尔。与此同时，帕姆还在试图弄清楚吉姆到底怎么了。她试图跟他讲一个故事，说自己遇到一个调戏她的老朋友，
and she's sorry she didn't tell him sooner. Hint, hint. She's sorry she kept it from him, hint, hint. And he says, no, no you didn't. You would have told me. And she's like, yeah, I would have told you. I would have told you. Yeah. Unlike something you're not telling me.
而且她很抱歉没有早点告诉他。暗示，暗示。她很抱歉瞒着他，暗示，暗示。而吉姆却说：不，不，你没有。你本来会告诉我的。她就说：对，我确实会告诉你。我会告诉你的。对。不像某件你一直瞒着我不说的事。
Jim still doesn't effing tell her. Jim, she knows. You've got to know she knows at this point. So uncomfortable. Well, now back to this Andy and Aaron, News Anchor Audition storyline. Remember how earlier I told you Pete is going to try to tell Aaron, this is a bad idea. This isn't going to work out. But it got deleted.
吉姆他妈的还是没告诉她。吉姆，她知道了。你到这时候一定知道她已经知道了。太尴尬了。好吧，现在回到安迪和艾琳的新闻主播试镜剧情线。还记得我刚才说过皮特试图告诉艾琳这是个坏主意吗？这行不通的。但这部分被删掉了。
It's in the deleted scenes. I want to play it for you. The way it's set up is Aaron is running some errands and she's waiting for the elevator, you know, in the lobby. Sure. And Pete walks up there alone while she waits for the elevator and he's going to say, hey, and share with her what he thinks about all this. Let's hear it.
它在删减片段里。我想放给你们听听。场景的设定是艾琳在跑腿，她在（大厅的）电梯口等电梯。没错。然后皮特独自走到她身边，趁她等电梯时，打算跟她聊聊，分享他对此事的看法。我们来听听。
Hey. Hey, I'm buying newspapers. Erin, this is a bad idea. I usually take the stairs. I just thought I would give myself a treat. I meant your audition. I just feel like the chances of this working out are a slim to none, you know, or are none to none. Like they start at none and then they just stay there.
嘿。嘿，我在买报纸。艾琳，这是个坏主意。我通常走楼梯。我只是觉得该犒劳自己一下。我是指你的试镜。我觉得这件事成功的几率微乎其微，你知道的，或者说根本是零。从一开始就是零，而且一直都是零。
That is not nice. I'm gonna take a stairs. I have a lot to say about this deleted scene. Okay. And here it is. It bothered me in this episode that Pete didn't just say the truth. Yeah. So in the shooting draft, when he approaches her at the elevator and he kind of fumbles through this, he says, this is never going to happen, right?
这样说话太不友善了。我要去走楼梯了。关于这段删减片段，我有很多话要说。好的。就是这样。这集里让我觉得不舒服的是，皮特为什么不直接说实话。对。所以在拍摄剧本中，当他在电梯口接近她时，他支支吾吾地说：这永远不会发生，对吧？
We just listen to it. Then he would have changed tactics. He would have been like, okay, that didn't work. But Pete in the shooting draft is determined to prevent her from going alone to Clark's apartment. And he comes up with this kind of ruse. Instead of calling out Clark as being a creeper, he just makes sure that Aaron is not alone. Well, that's all fine and good, Angela,
我们刚刚听到了。然后他本该改变策略的。他本该说：好吧，这招不管用。但在拍摄剧本中，皮特下定决心要阻止她独自去克拉克的公寓。于是他想出了这么个借口。与其直接指责克拉克是个变态，他只是确保艾琳不会独自一人。好吧，这倒也无可厚非，安吉拉，
but I wish he would have just said the truth. Yeah, we don't need to protect the creepers, I guess is my point. Oh, absolutely. But I did want to show that he was trying throughout this to deter her. Ultimately, what happens is Andy Pete and Aaron show up to Clark's apartment. Yes.
但我希望他当时能直接说实话。对，我想说的是，我们没必要去保护变态。哦，绝对的。但我确实想表现出他一直在试图阻止她。最终发生的情况是，安迪、皮特和艾琳一起出现在了克拉克的公寓。对。
Andy is now the co-anchor. Yes. And he's taking his job very seriously. I love it when Clark's like, I think you guys got it. And he's like, no, I didn't. I don't got it. She did great. She did great.
安迪现在成了联合主播。对。而且他把工作看得无比严肃。我太喜欢克拉克说“我觉得你们挺有天赋”时，安迪却回答说：“不，我没有天赋。她很有天赋。她表现得太棒了。”
I need a close-up. I need you to go in tighter. Yeah. Aaron, why don't you go have dinner with Pete? All of this backfires for Clark. And it also shows how Andy doesn't see Aaron. He just sees himself always. Yeah, I did appreciate the reveals of this storyline.
我需要一个特写。我需要你把镜头拉得更近一点。对。艾琳，你为什么不和皮特去吃晚饭呢？所有这些对克拉克来说都适得其反。这也展现了安迪根本看不见艾琳。他眼里永远只有自己。对，我很欣赏这条剧情线的反转。
Well, I'll have you know, Clark's apartment was located on Kester Avenue in Sherman Oaks. We shot these scenes after all of the stuff at Roy's house. It was a really big day for our crew. They had to do what is called a company move where they pack up everything from one location and move to a second location. It's a big deal. So this was a long day for them. It was a long day and it was triple digits outside. Yeah. And then the diner that we shot at, we did actually shoot this on a different day. This was the hungry fox on Sherman Way and Van Aes. It is right by our studio. It was Greg's
嗯，我得告诉你，克拉克的公寓位于谢尔曼奥克斯的凯斯特大道。我们在拍完罗伊家的所有戏份之后才拍了这些场景。这对我们的剧组来说是非常重要的一天。他们必须进行所谓的“剧组搬迁”，即把一个地方的所有东西打包并搬到第二个地方。这可是一件大事。所以对他们来说这是漫长的一天。这是漫长的一天，而且外面气温高达三位数（华氏度）。是的。然后我们拍摄的那个餐馆，我们实际上是在另一天拍的。这是位于谢尔曼大道和范奈斯的“饥饿狐狸”。它就在我们工作室旁边。这是格雷格的
favorite place. He would go there in the mornings before work and eat breakfast and go over his notes and do his thinking. And then he would come into work. We also shot some Roy Pam scenes there. It's really good food. I have to tell you, one morning I was driving into work and I went early. I was very pregnant and I just was like, I want a big, big breakfast before I even walk onto set. So I got up really early.
最爱去的地方。他会在上班前的早晨去那里吃早餐，温习剧notes并思考。然后他再去上班。我们还在那里拍了一些罗伊和帕姆的戏。那里的食物真的很好吃。我必须告诉你，有一天早晨我开车去上班，我去的很早。我当时怀孕月份很大，我当时就想，在我走进片场之前，我想要一顿非常丰盛的早餐。所以我起得很早。
I wasn't sleeping great anyway towards the end of your pregnancy. You know you don't really feel great. And I went to the hungry fox so early and I ordered myself this huge breakfast and in walked Greg. Yeah. And he was like,
反正到了怀孕后期我睡眠也不太好。你知道你感觉真的不太好。我那么早就去了“饥饿狐狸”，给自己点了一顿丰盛的早餐，然后格雷格走了进来。是的。他当时说，
what are you doing here? I was like, I was just really hungry. And so we had breakfast together. Well everyone, that was Roy's wedding. A big thank you to Tim Meadows. Yes. For joining us, everybody, please go see our Mean Girls movie. It opens this Friday.
你在这里做什么？我说，我只是真的很饿。所以我们一起吃了早餐。好了各位，那是罗伊的婚礼。非常感谢蒂姆·米多斯。是的。感谢你加入我们，大家请去看我们的《贱女孩》电影。本周五上映。
We had so much fun making it. And, oh my gosh, I'm excited to see it on the big screen. I'm so excited. My daughter's so excited. A bunch of her friends are going to see it. Jenna, this is so fun. It's my big moment, it's a big moment. And also, of course, thank you to Steve Burgess
我们拍得很开心。而且，天哪，我很高兴能在银幕上看到它。我太兴奋了。我女儿也太兴奋了。她的一群朋友都要去看。珍娜，这太有趣了。这是我的高光时刻，这是一个大时刻。当然，也要感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯
and to all of you for writing in with your questions and your great observations. Yes, and I would say thank you to Miles McNut. Oh, for two years of awesome reviews that were always interesting, if not hilarious. We'll be looking for you in the comments. That's right. We'll see you guys next week.
以及感谢你们所有人的提问和精彩的观察。是的，我要感谢迈尔斯·麦克纳特。哦，感谢他两年来的精彩评论，不仅总是很有趣，而且让人捧腹大笑。我们会在评论区寻找你们的。没错。我们下周见。
See you then! [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keeper. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco.
回头见！[♪ 片尾音乐播放中 [♪ 感谢收听 Office Ladies。《Office Ladies》由 Earwolf、Jennifer Fisher 和 Angela Kinsey 制作。我们的资深制作人是 Cassie Jerkins。我们的录音室工程师是 Sam Keeper。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是 Jordan Duffy，我们的助理制作人是 Ainsley Bubbaco。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是 Creed Bratton 创作的《Rubber Tree》。你 本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。